[Music]
the title match is underway here in the
2023 Champions chess tour final it's
Magnus Carlson versus Wesley so in a
rematch of their round robin battle
earlier this week where despite epic
chess from both players in the end it
was Wesley so the underdog who took home
the victory over the world number one
will he be all smiles again here today
at the end of the title match we'll find
out cuz the show starts right
now I think
I you've heard the sayings The Road Less
Traveled rubber meets the road I'm on
the road to nowhere that need to get up
and go to just shut up and drive to
Parts Unknown it's in our DNA but this
road Road has an end and the
beginning well let's throw that in
Reverse it's over we have a winner
Magnus Carlson what has this kid got in
store he
might one move Checkmate there's been
curves Hills corners and even a
breakdown or two the game is over that's
we see a reaction Magnus Magus mousli oh
my gosh look at Jordan's face some have
pulled over but some oh what is he doing
Slamm that foot to the floor and just
kept going any second Nakamura is the
winner not ABD Maxim vajra the Frenchman
he wins the AI cup after six stops along
the way it's time for the greatest
proven ground and online chest to drop
that final pin in the
GPS destination Toronto Canada eight
players from all four corners of the
globe descend on the Queen City with one
goal to prove who the one true king of
online chess really is I think this is
the strongest final there's ever been I
know that it will not be easy it's nice
to play in top tournament Magnus will
want revenge it's my last tournament of
the year I'm a bit desperate to end it
well having the opportunity to play
against the best players in the world
it's always a challenge and I enjoy it
it's going to be a very close fight it's
going to be very exciting live from
Toronto Canada this is the 2023
Champions chess tour finals and it
starts
[Music]
now well he may be desperate to end it
well Wesley so is going to have a chance
to do so as we look across the beautiful
Lake Ontario one of the largest lakes in
North America and you see the CN tower
she's always there gazing upon the
entire city as fans will gaze upon the
chess here in Toronto it is time for the
title match the 2023 Champions chess
tour final this is what we've been
waiting for Danny rench James KY Levy
Rosman guys you can feel the energy you
can feel the nerves the semis are done
Levy your first thoughts on the final we
made it my first thoughts are if you
combine that top and that top you get me
I I like
that was that did we plan that we we
spend more time together I'm pumped we
have an opportunity to see a Revenge
Magnus beating everybody in the round
robin stage except Wesley so who went
perfect to start six and0 obviously
succumbing to the uh last round of
Fabiano Carana but Magnus out for
Revenge we have two days of action this
is an amazing matchup because Wesley has
had success against Magnus in Rapid this
year so Wesley Wesley and you know
Wesley in Toronto in fact you know hence
the name flexy Toronto right he actually
it's proven fact he gets 100 ELO when
he's here in Toronto only so you got
goat and then you have you know Wesley
so who's on 100 ELO just because he's in
Toronto how he did you prepare that run
I did that was hotot I 100 plus ELO he's
in Toronto let's go the show flow moves
across to the bracket let's remind
everybody of how they got here the semis
were exciting Wesley so fell behind of
duat turov if you forgot that he had to
complete a comeback and that's what gave
us a very long day of Chess yesterday
Magnus Carlson won but it took
Armageddon twice will we look back on
that match up with Carana and say that
that was actually the toughest closest
match or will Wesley so do what he's
done before and beat Magnus Carlson in a
match not just here but many remember
the 2019 fishal random World
Championship oh man these guys are are
uh are out for blood you know cuz I
think Magnus doesn't like the fact that
some people think Wesley can beat him in
this format I don't know what do you
think about that oh definitely I mean
Magnus you know he he was showing up
early I want to hear yall predictions
just to make sure you're predicting
against me so I can use that right so
the world like hey we we're rooting for
Wesley right but of course Magnus like
yeah I want you to root for wesy that's
what I needed today that motivation I
will say uh and to the fans at home who
who are aware this is very much a
situation where the world knows who the
favorite is based on past experience
almost like a joke ofage showing up to a
final the whole tournament we're sitting
going is he going to make the final well
now he's in the final we see his
opponent almost feels like even though
we are all fans of Magnus and probably
Wesley we're secretly kind of rooting
for Wesley for a big upset here just
just just a little chaos we all love
chaos we all want a little drama little
chaos at the top look we had drama
yesterday as well we talked about how
they got there with the bracket we
showed you let's give you a little bit
of a highlight reel of how things went
down
the stage is set for the deciding match
of the Champions chess tour finals the
finalists Magnus Carlson and Wesley so
are no strangers to each other on the
world stage historically Magnus has been
the dominant player in classical chess
their record is five wins for Magnus one
win for Wesley and 15
draws Wesley is a three-time US chess
champion and a former Fisher random
world champion defeating Magnus to claim
the inaugural title in
2019 last year he won the chess.com
Global champion I ship also hosted in
Toronto while an impressive achievement
there was one player missing from those
finals Magnus
Carlson the current world number one and
highest rated player ever the name needs
almost no introduction the five-time
world chess champion many consider
Magnus to be the greatest chess player
ever after two days and four rounds
Wesley and Magnus were the only ones
with perfect scores going into their
match against one another after two
accurate draws it was Wesley that took
at home in Armageddon winning with a
bold sacrifice early on the round robin
finished with Wesley and Magnuson first
and second respectively allowing them to
skip the survival stage the winners to
emerge from the survival stage were
Fabiano kowana and Notre Abdus
toov Wesley had a choice in opponent for
the semi-final and wanting to avoid the
world number two he chose notb this made
for a 2018 World Chess Championship
rematch with Magnus and Fabiano after
trading wins with the white pieces
Fabiano stole a game with the black
pieces all he needed to secure the first
set was a draw with white but Magnus had
other ideas an early blunder from Fabby
spelled the end of that game and set one
was sent to Armageddon despite magnus's
winning position with the black pieces
he used his draw odds to his advantage
and went for a forc repetition line
spotted miles away Fabiano spotted it
too but in his effort to avoid it his
position worsened ending in a win for
Magnus and he could just throw in the
towel Magnus Carlson brilliant tactical
awareness to take this Armageddon that
is set one do Magnus set two was just as
heartbreaking for Fabiano losing an
Armageddon once again marking the end of
his run here in
Toronto in the other semi-final Wesley
started out strong winning the first
game of set one notb back then came back
winning the next two games showing
incredible Poise in critical moments
with mere seconds on the clock in the
fourth game notb found a three-fold
repetition to get a draw and win the set
the next day Wesley Came Out Swinging
winning the first two games of the set
notb found a win on Demand with the
black pieces in the next game but drew
the last one to lose the set tied at one
set a piece the pair entered into a
final best of two set to determine who
would go to the finals after two tense
draws we were treated to one last
Armageddon for the day with immense
pressure and $50,000 on the line for a
single game Notre backck succumb to
nerves and time pressure allowing Wesley
to find a winning end game with a
massive time Advantage he's got no time
as well and lost on the board
these are the final few seconds of nck
in the Champions Chester finals and the
queen can take this night a new Queen
will appear nck knows it he resigns Wes
Leo is into the finals great
[Music]
match it's been a grueling week of Rapid
chess in Toronto one match remains to
determine a winner at the Champions
chess tour finals who will it be Magnus
Carlson or Wesley
so
I think that was a proper tribute a
proper homage to the players who are no
longer with us in Toronto love those
shots of them exiting the door but it's
down to two down to two it's down to two
yeah it's Magnus it's Wesley Wesley we
start with the goat your thoughts Magnus
well Magnus always wants to win we know
that not only in just the mental but the
physical I actually saw him at the gym
yesterday like literally I was just you
know going to the restroom and the Gym's
right there he was walking into into the
gym to work out and I was like wow the
mental and the physical is there as
Wesley so even mentioned as well too he
was like yeah you know he's just a
little bit more fit at the top level and
you can see that he didn't went out to
the Leafs game to see some other guys do
their thing Magnus is ready to go at all
levels Magnus also has said frequently
that he thinks Fabiano Carana is the the
clear number two in the world and he
might feel like he already got the job
done and Wesley is sort of the the next
in line he might feel like it's a little
bit of a weight off his shoulders we see
the head-to-head they have played so
many freaking games against each other
3117 is wild I mean it's it's draws is
wild 39 draws is wild yeah but of course
they've played let's Qui quick math 87
games of Rapid is what that was and
remember fans that stat was just rapid
yeah just rapid it's not
classic so many times and I a better
stat is what is Wesley's win percentage
in all three types of formats that that
was that was 317 so that's like a good
that's a good basketball team you know
like a third place basketball team right
there Wesley's beaten him 17 times and
this year he's beaten him a couple of
times as well so
we'll see which Wesley shows up Magnus
is doing Magnus things we'll see which
Wesley shows up to battle Magnus let's
remind everybody of all those Magnus
things that he has done here through the
first six days in Toronto a s and3
record overall in his uh in his white
and black games there misread that one
but I want to jump to the brilliancies
by the way he's played eight of them wow
that's tight for most with Wesley so
that's a fun little stat right there a
5- one Armageddon overall record candy
biggest stat that jumps out to you on
the a scoreboard that 5 to one that 5 to
one overall is the biggest for me I mean
obviously the a brilli seon is nasty too
but that 5 to one and guess who gave him
that one Danny that's right it was
Wesley the question is always can you
stop Magnus Wesley has done it already
once today but now more games in the
match yep we heard Hikaru on his way out
say that if Magnus gets more games yeah
it's obviously more of an opportunity
for him to make a comeback if he goes
down in a match or if the match is tied
we saw it against Fabiano come I'm want
to go back to the fact that that match
was a barn burner two times it went to
Armageddon versus Fabiano and Magnus
still managed to overcome yeah and
Wesley roaring back against nck Ian it's
pretty clear both of these guys deserve
to be here yeah so now we're just going
to have to see who the champ is who the
champ The champ is here these guys do
deserve to be here we're happy you're in
here with us another person who's in
here with us right now is Kaa she's been
patiently waiting for a chance to jump
in so Ka good morning hey Kaa morning Ka
good morning Donnie yeah it's uh
patiently is the word I mean these
chairs are so comfortable you can fall
asleep here I don't know how the players
sit here for such a long time just so
energetic and that's what is all about
today you know we started out back in
January with hundreds of players in the
first qualification we took the top
eight players here to Toronto they have
been fighting it out now since Saturday
we are now left with two chairs two
players to fight it out for the ultimate
title and well Magnus Carlson he is now
known as the goat after traveling around
for chess for many years is now in
asking the question who is the best
chess player of all time so many times I
heard people answer Gary Kasparov Gary
Kasparov but more often now over the
last few years people start answering
Magnus Carlson and uh let's hear what
the other players here in Toronto said
about Magnus Carlson before the
tournament
started uh so first of all what is your
take on Magnus Carlson growing up he was
my idol because when I started playing
chess he became World Champion 2013 it's
always pretty cool I play against him
and I'm happy that I managed to be
quickly in the top so I could compete
against him so he's really exceptional
player
and amazing Champion I mean he still is
the best player by far I would say uh I
don't think he's as motivated in chess
as he once used to be Mar Carlson is of
course he's incredibly strong it's very
hard to play against him well Magnus
Carson um could definitely be be
considered the greatest player of all
time or at least in a close battle with
uh with Gary Casper yeah it'll be
interesting to play against him see his
form um and hopefully at least some of
us can put up a good fight and maybe
maybe beat him uh the difference between
me and Magnus was uh like 300 tour
points so it means uh it means a lot so
I think that speaks for itself uh as
people like to
say he's ad Tied by his peers he's
feared by his peers they uh they look at
his chest and they look at what he does
they're always impressed Magnus Carl and
Larger than Life in many ways larger
than chess and speaking of larger than
just the chess in here we now have a fan
Zone that we got to check in with chess
braas okay are going to be holding it
down live at a bar not too far from here
there are already fans in there we see a
few of them I think there's uh there's a
lot of fans in there we're we're we're
seeing through oh somebody's filming
right there Eric and Aman are going to
be posting if you're looking for a
different flavor of commentary you can
head over to the chess bra Channel as
they will have the call with a lot of
fans who will probably have a great and
a safe time is that Ari onari right
there that is arar right there Grand
Master is that a that is a Norwegian
grandmas but all right those are the
fans who are here to cheer for Magnus
well guess what last night Magnus
Carlson was a fan as he went to the
Leafs game and he was cheering for a
score that it didn't look like they were
having a great time I mean just at that
they were down 5 n I'm sure they were
having fun anyway but Levy tell the fans
if they missed it what happened in that
one yeah that's all I saw I did not
actually see the update until this
morning I thought this was hilarious you
know you take Magnus Carlson to a suite
in a hockey game and the the home team's
down 5 nothing well the Toronto Maple
Leaf scored five goals in the third
period which sources have told us has
never been done before but there's going
to be hockey fans in the chat that might
disagree or we are just totally wrong
the Toronto Maple Le score five goals in
the third period to tie the score and
then lose in overtime oh man perfect
perfect strategy for a Toronto hockey
team perfect strategy they they you know
they lose in overtime you do get points
for going for overtime but all right
we're we're over time right now on
Magnus it's time for us to move across
to Wesley so and I'm going to you're the
guy who gives him the nickname who just
Serano seen it you've seen him do it now
two years in a row your thoughts well
100% I mean last year when he did win
you know the cgc I mean the big money
prize there all the players he had to go
through and it was very very strong
field I mean you see him here in Toronto
he feels so good you can tell he's in
great fous and he does get that extra
100 ELO that carries over from last year
just because what he did last year in
Toronto he already took off Magnus to as
well I mean he's trying to do it again
yep and here's how he got there if you
uh forgot he did it in comeback fashion
over Notre Becka D turov he was down but
he showed up on Thursday not one but two
three really if you consider the
Armageddon matches and uh Levy back to
you your thoughts on Wesley so and
whether that chess has a chance to
continue now that he's facing Carlson
listen to Tonto has been his City last
year he knocks out Hikaru and then he
wins the entire thing this time he's the
top seed he chooses n abov he makes it
as dramatic as possible so we get more
viewership he wins the Armageddon after
an eight match day he picked his
opponent and he got he got he sent
Magnus the hardest opponent he could
possibly find Magnus overcame the
challenge so now Wesley's going to have
to take down Magnus that' be some epic
stuff I love the call there because as a
guy who's been accused of scripting a
few things in the Chess World I will say
that if you were to script some content
in terms of how Magnus Carlson falls
behind against Fabi Carana not once but
twice epic comeback in Armageddon I
guess Fabby sent the sent the second one
armag and then Wesley so finds a way to
give us the most possible chess he could
the round robin where they threw down
speaking of giving all that he could to
chess was a big match because Wesley so
after losing an armagedon bid quote
unquote losing Magnus W black Wesley
blew him off the board yeah he
sacrificed a knight upon a rook right he
complet you didn't scream it no I didn't
scream it you know I'm trying to save my
voice for the screams a little bit later
but uh incredible game his his six days
in Toronto we have that up on the screen
I mean he's tied with the most
brilliancies with Magnus that's that's
really all we got to look at they should
have just put that bullet point up on
the screen and uh yeah he's the only one
to defeat Magnus in a match here in
Toronto this looks exactly the same I
mean I was looking I was like is it like
did they change it production no it's
exactly it's the same one in Armageddon
I mean it's crazy they're the same
person in a different Universe
Spider-Man meme I mean KY you're making
a great point it the stats are just
strikingly similar right I mean they
have both played the best chess of any
two people and I guess that's why
they're still here standing and still
here with us inside the playing Hall is
Kaa she's been waiting again to weigh in
on so Ka what you got for
us yeah still here Dan still in this
comfortable secret lab chair and I'm
sitting by one of the boards so we
started out obviously with four tables
four boards uh today there will only be
play on one board this is not the board
so that means I'm allowed to touch the
pieces I'm not going to screw up any dgt
stuff here and it's going to be
interesting right to see when the
players come they always uh organized
their pieces the way they wanted shadub
Magnus Carlson always puts his kns like
this Wesley so however he likes to have
them facing towards the heart both
Knights facing like this so this is what
Wesley will do when he comes to the
board today to play the first game with
the white pieces he is the top seed
remember so I want to ask you guys what
do you think will be the first move in
the big final when Wes Leo has the the
white pieces in game
one it's hard to guess first moves but
I'm going to guess that he doesn't play
one E4 he struggled with one E4 against
Notre Beck Abdus saurov a couple of his
losses came with that and he told me
hanging on the lounge that he was not
too happy with the opening there so will
he play 1 B3 I guess I'll guess that for
funsies but I don't I don't think we're
going to see E4 wow that's that's a good
uh good good observation I actually
thought he would play E4 because of
based off the interview that you gave
with him and he was like yeah you know
favorite opening he said E4 I was like
oh cool E4 so feels like that but you
have a great point he just didn't do
well with E4 against Abdus Toro yeah
yeah I'm going to predict that E4 you
don't know if Magnus will play E5 or C5
E5 is symmetrical it's going to be a
Spanish or an Italian and he will ease
into the match or Magnus could just show
up guns blazing with a sicilian right
and I I kind of feel like Wesley might
want to ease into it and play a D4
because that kind of controls the action
we're going to get a traditional Queen's
Pawn the D and C pawns but I mean he
might show up and do whatever he wants
but my guess is D4 I like that take
though if he doesn't want to fight in
game one maybe avoid E4 because of the
Sicilian Kaa what do you
think no I'm just going to say what I'm
hoping for and that is exact same as you
Danny I'm hoping for the B3 I love that
opening so much fun and Wesley so well
he is here ready to fight this means so
much to Wesley so to be able to fight
for it and maybe have the chance to win
the Champions chess tour 20123 we did
sit down with him before the tournament
to talk about what's at
stare so we are here in Toronto I am H
Kaa excited for the CCT finals here with
Wesley so nice to be here in Toronto yes
it's good to I'm also very excited and
it's good to see you back after such a
long time only eight of you made it here
to Toronto so what makes you excited I
did very well last year yeah hopefully
it's a good sign and uh it's the same
place you know this one of my most
favorite pels from last year so
hopefully that's a good sign what are uh
the fans in for this week you know
things are going to happen very quickly
right from the very beginning there's a
lot in stake here so players are going
to be very competitive and uh obviously
some time ago you learned that the
finals would be over the board what was
your reaction to that in I know if you
know but we're playing in a computer
right no no we're playing over the board
oh we're playing in a real board yeah
yeah oh so you're learning that now yeah
I was quite confused I don't know what
mag has been doing playing online all
this time
then wa okay so thank you yeah can you
describe your playing style when I was
younger I would always play 1 E4 and
play the Sicilian with black like I was
very aggressive I'd go for mating
attacks but I could not play the end
game and then when I turned 16 I
started reading a lot of opening books
and then when I reached 2600 I realized
that you cannot just go for the attack
every single game and hope to win
because 2600s are not stupid they will
they will bring you down what would it
mean to to to win it at wesle it would
be amazing uh my last tourament of the
year it's really it's really a big deal
uh this year it's much stronger though
than last year you got Magnus you got
sappi you got hikaro so there's a lot
ins wly so thank you and good luck in
the CCT
[Music]
finals well we know how much he would
want to win and here are the odds for
him to win according to the chess.com
stats team at this point Point based on
a a long and lengthy kind of probability
algorithm simulation I'm not going to
tell you how we arrived at this cuz I
think most people tend to agree with it
Magnus was a 50% favorite coming in
Wesley 7 now it's uh it's a it's a
quarter perent 25% chance according to
75% but all right there's a chance both
players are about to come in right now
and they typically like to get ready so
I think I think we're going to get out
of here let's throw it across the sea
the Atlantic tatanya Robert and David we
know know you guys are waiting you're as
excited I'm sure as we are to see what
action goes down on the board so Tanya
how you doing today I'm doing good Danny
I'm super excited about everything
that's coming up we've been building up
to this moment all year round the fight
for the championship and it is between
the two best performers the top two
finishers of the round robin is the
world champion taking on the global
Champion Clash of the Titans however you
look at it how does Wesley defy those
odds today rob it well we've been really
waiting for this class for over a year
since Wesley so took down the 2022
chess.com Global championship and Magnus
Carlson won the 2022 Champions chess
tour so these two players they came in
as defending Champions only one of them
can escape and keep their Crown who will
it be Wesley or Magnus I think Magnus
has to be the favorite as I always say
but Wesley will give him all he can
handle yeah it feels like a unification
match in some way and it's just a
tantalizing Prospect if we see anything
like the chess we saw when these two met
in the round Robbin stage then I'm going
to get my popcorn out and just enjoy but
yes Magnus I think undoubtedly even
Wesley so will admit he starts as a
favorite but he cannot relax one move
one slip up and Wesley will be ready to
punish him yeah Magnus gson it's hard to
bet against the world number one
regardless of who he's playing and we
had such a big semi-final battle both
Magnus and Wesley put on this phenomenal
fight for Wesley it went down to the
wire Magnus was able to wrap it up with
without a set three do you think stamina
fatigue is a factor at this point well I
feel like that Magnus match in some ways
was just as close as the Wesley so win
over nbea batara because Magnus won in
two consecutive armagedon it was tied
two games a piece Fabiano actually took
three decisive games off of Magnus not
something that many people can say in
this world so both players will be
exhausted it's the seventh day of an
eight day stretch here so I think that
both players will have to give all
that's left in the reserve tank
and Wesley so did get the job done
against Magnus Carlson in the round
robin he it went all the way to the
Armageddon but Wesley with probably one
of the best played games of the finals
so far he took the match in that one
he's got to find that same chest that
same provocative aggressive play as he
did in that one uh David that was a
memorable encounter Wesley throwing
sacrifices out there going straight
directly for magnus's King he needs more
of the same he cannot be too
differential here he cannot give Magnus
too much respect it's going to be a long
match over today and tomorrow but Wesley
will need to take his chances he will
need to uh show that same level of
attack of aggression uh that he
displayed in that one game yeah that
move Knight to G5 what a move that was
finishing uh the game in the armagan at
least starting the attack and eventually
finishing the game now for wesy it's a
big question right it was a different
format in the round robin it was a a
shter format with just two rapid games
going into Armageddon this is a best of
three set and today set one are we
expecting Wesley in a best of four match
to take a more kg approach or does he as
David was saying go go for it take make
the most of the opportunities from the
very start against Magnus if I'm Wesley
so I go with my tried and true method I
play Solly against this man right here
world number one Magnus Carlson doesn't
matter if he's out late watching hockey
he always brings it on the chess board
you see the players they're about to get
set
we will see Wesley's opening approach in
just a few seconds will it be the king
spawn opening or the Queen spawn opening
or how Ka predicted perhaps we might see
another 1 V3 I'd be surprised if we see
another Cowboy chess here thank you so
much
for starts with possible thank you so
much start your G Ready set go we're off
and it's the finals the Champions chest
store
2023 glasses off business time Wesley so
he's got to choose his first move which
porn it's the title match he does adjust
Jad the king and it is 1 B3 Magnus
Carlson shakes his head he is surprised
Magnus was not expecting this I can't
tell if he's more surprised or offended
B3 is not an opening you see at the
highest levels of Chess at least not in
this time control you usually see it in
Blitz chess but Magnus probably didn't
take it so seriously considering Wesley
he seemed to use it just to get
something Magnus has not even played his
very first move wow not many people in
World Chess have the courage to play
this type of opening against Magnus
Carlson usually they're trying to occupy
the center trying to force the issue and
look at Magnus he's bemused he's uh just
shocked here looking up at the ceiling
just trying to pick uh how to react to
this shock this surprise and eventually
he plays a bit of CopyCat Mirror Image
here he gets ready to Fe in ketto
Blackstar Square Bishop playing G6 the
Knight out and will Take This Night Big
stylistic Choice white is flexible no he
just pushes a pawn and okay we see the
first mind games at work and Magnus
Carlton himself has employed 1 B3 with
the white side definitely something that
yes Wesley won a game against nbec Abdu
satov in the semi-finals but nobody
could have expected this seriously to
happen against we were talking about
this being the anti- young player chess
approach in the opening the guy Wesley's
facing right now he's not exactly a
young player well he could you could
argue still be in his prime and I can't
believe that I of all people am about to
say this did Magnus prepare by looking
at Twitter or X whatever you want to
call it the answer is likely no but
Wesley asked the question what should I
do he posed that question to Fabiana
Carana and fabbi said the key to playing
Magnus jokingly is to prepare for and
against 1 B3 so we have that opening on
the board we're going to have Fen kto
from both of Black's Bishops on the
longest diagonals and Wesley he was the
first to surprise Magnus now he's the
one in the think tank there is no
combative play no tension between pieces
just yet yeah we're going to have a lot
of fun from the start we were discussing
whether this will be a kg start a more
solid approach but it's clear that
Wesley wants to start with with energy
in a combative manner in an unexpected
opening approach here David what's the
best strategy when you're taken by
surprise early on perhaps Magnus was was
considering that B3 would be an option
but maybe not taking it that seriously
how do you approach that situation on
the board yeah it feels like there's
always two different parts you can take
when you're surprised one you think okay
I'm being surprised here I want to kind
of rise to the challenge Fight Fire with
Fire I'm going to punish my opponent for
their tarity in playing such an opening
or you just think I want to survive I
want to kind of uh negotiate the opening
navigate that safely just get a solid
position as long as I've weathered the
storm uh I will be able to fight on
level turns a bit later and Robert what
do you think is this Magnus taking Fire
by fire or just uh saying you know what
you got the first surprise in I'm
playing to equalize her he's played some
feeler moves thus far but I did see him
roll up his sleeves and so he looks
locked in and ready to fight for the
center from the black side you can
always push the C Pawn up two squares in
fact by playing B6 early on not only are
you welcoming a faneto light Square
Bishop but you can fight for the center
in this manner using your your C Pawn to
combat a d pawn and Magnus he delays
that choice he castles kingside both
players are playing normal moves at this
stage I would say now that the opening
surprise is past us and past them it's
about who's about to come up with a plan
yeah both sides are super flexible right
now Wesley can push a bunch of different
pawns most likely the white king is
going to copy and castle on the king
side within the next few turns but
whether white fing ketos his light
squared Bishop as well is the first
question uh Wesley now mulling those
questions over if white does fetto then
we'll see all four Bishops on the
longest possible diagonals all kind of
neutralizing each other and uh roughly
level play there White's kind of Pride
and Joy right now is the pawn Center
White has extra space in the middle so
Wesley will be trying to figure out to
in way to ensure that uh is maintained
over the next few moves but he's peering
into the future he's trying to work out
a plan of action the next half dozen
moves also and uh this is kind of a good
moment to pause because we are reaching
the end of the opening the surprise is
over as Robert says and um it will soon
be about those middle game plans well
you might see copycat chess when it
comes to the Bishops the center
definitely is uh just for now Advantage
Wesley with space but that means for
Magnus it's going to be about getting a
break in the center in once you're
finished with the development you want
to strike with either the cwn moving
forward and that would be my choice of
break in these kind of setups to
eventually Force Wesley to decide what
he wants to do with those bonds it's
always nice to control the center but
when somebody establishes their pawns on
the fourth rank like this you can
challenge them with one simple pawn move
we're talking about the C5 Pawn push if
Wesley ever decides to push pawns even
further that's closer to Black's clamp
easier to Chisel Camp I should say
easier to Chisel at that Center and so
for Wesley he's deciding how to continue
his development here I would be F King
but I'm wondering if Wesley's looking at
this position saying we're on neutral
ground both of us out of whatever
semblance of preparation we could have
had it's like I don't love my position
because I don't know what to do next
it's actually coming up with a plan not
just individual moves yeah and Wesley
for a while he had his head in hands I
was wondering whether he was napping
catching up with some much needed sleep
there but it feels like he's just
indecisive feels like he's Frozen
somewhat this is a lot of time to invest
at this early stage we're still only on
move five as we see with the move
counter on the top left hand of your
screens and he's looking away from the
board he's uh just mulling over it's a
stylistic choice he knows he's got
basically two options of setting up his
pieces especially when it comes to
developing his light squared bishop and
at some point he just needs to choose
there's no right or wrong answer it's
just what he's in the mood for
ultimately these minutes that he's
spending will be much needed later on in
the game are we getting shades of that
Carana Carlson game where Fabiano spent
way too much time in that game four of
set one of course this position is a lot
different than that game but right now
Wesley could play a number of moves
quite quickly I just wouldn't advise
getting in time trouble against mag
Carlson especially when you're both in
this territory where you're unfamiliar
with the starting position here I think
that Wesley shouldn't be worried there's
he's done nothing wrong but he's
spending a lot of time and we've seen
Wesley be shaky even by his own words
even what nck was saying in time trouble
so for Magnus he should be feeling good
he's looking confident sitting across
from Wesley right now more than a three
minute thing by Wesley so at this early
early stage of the game and the two
choices that David was refering to
either moves the King Pawn forward or
decides to develop the bishop on the G2
Square he goes for the latter the fian
king and we see the Bishops facing each
other what kind of middle games does
this um opening setup get into does this
mean that white eventually wants to try
to get more space in the center perhaps
pushing the ewn not one step but two
steps forward if allowed yeah I think he
would love that Wesley so if allowed but
he is slightly behind in development
here because black is already castled
White's next move pretty much is
guaranteed to be uh getting the white
King to safety castling himself and uh
Magnus will therefore have a move maybe
even two moose uh to challenge the black
uh challenge the White Center and here
we go he gets ready to do so uh he first
pushes this Pawn so that he can next I
think Robert y move potentially push the
black C pawn and prevent white from
stepping forward gaining even more space
but no Magnus staying very flexible here
uh putting a knight on the rim it
doesn't look like a great square but
later it might hop back towards the
center he's just getting the pieces out
and this is the downside the
double-edged sword of being creative
freestyling in the opening for Wesley so
yes you've got a healthy position a
playable position but it's cost you a
lot of time probably it's going to cost
you a lot more time because still so
many options on every single move and
Magnus being non-committal is actually a
good Approach at this stage because
black can choose which Pawn to push
either the C Pawn to challenge the D4
Pawn or his D Pawn go up to D5 to
challenge the C4 Pawn he has options
here and Knight A6 keeps both of those
options alive as the Knight A6 actually
helps in the event that you want to play
C5 instead of inad of recapturing with
the pawn you recapture with the Knight
gaining control of that key E4 Square so
white cannot push any more Pawns in the
center of the board at this stage black
is ready to do that so Wesley has to
think which direction is Magnus going to
go down Magnus has not made his
intentions clear he hasn't but it has to
be around these Central breaks that
we're talking about and it might not
even be a choice we might see both these
pawns moving forward eventually with
maximum tension in the center
visualizing opening ideas with the pawns
moving forward the queen side stepping
to E7 the black Rooks coming to the
center of the board you get C5 D5 in and
that feels like the ideal opening
development that you want with black
what about the white species where do
you want to place them in the structure
and this is the issue this is why
Wesley's burning even more time on the
clock right now he would love to for
example put his Knight on C3 if he gets
more time with white he would love to
put his Rook across to E1 and throw
another Pawn into the middle but the
problem in this type of position as is
well known in these types of what we
call Queens Indian structures where
black F and on the queen side black
often just plonks a knight onto this E4
Square And Trades off black was slightly
cramped due to White having a big Pawn
Center here so any trade of minor pieces
tends to free up Black's position of
course this isn't the only approach uh
Black's Knight doesn't have to jump in
Black could go for one of those Pawn
breaks we mentioned but uh this is what
forced Wesley to think twice before
bringing his Knight out he was scared of
a trade of knights opening up this
darkart Square Bishop so instead he
simply pushes a pawn forward this is
really timid play uh really kind of
non-committal play by either side I
think they're both waiting for Magnus to
kind of strike out in the center and he
does now we will see what happens with
these Central pawns likely another one
incoming soon even more so than these
Pawn breaks in the center I'm looking at
the clock Magnus has built a nearly
4minute lead on time and if you're
Wesley here he takes in the center so a
little bit has been clarified I'm
wondering if you're keeping one eye on
the clock to make sure that you don't
get yourself into too much time trouble
Magnus has not recaptured yet you think
that when someone captures your piece
you just take back but look at how many
pieces he can capture back he will not
be taking back with the queen that would
be a blunder we typically do not want to
lead with the queen when so many pieces
are on the board but he can capture say
with the pawn that would be the most
normal looking move and he does just
that but he was thinking perhaps I take
with the bishop to keep the diagonal
open yeah he takes with the pawn
establishing a long-term presence there
now space is pretty much level um the
pawn structure slightly imbalanced white
has an extra Pawn on the E file black
has an extra Pawn on the C file black
controls the pawn breaks and it's just
about whether Magnus kind of takes a
slower maneuvering approach right now or
whether he lashes out and puts another
Pawn in the center black can put a Pawn
on C5 challenge in the middle and we'll
see maximum tension it depends on
magnus's mood he's uh kind of mixing and
matching the plans this is one you
mentioned earlier Tanya just bringing
the black Rooks to the center looks very
healthy for Magnus Carson right now but
still uh in the balance and another plan
that comes to play after this trade of
Pawns in the center is the fight for the
E4 Square now uh Magnus can line up on
the E Line get that Rook going and even
jump in with that Knight to E4 meanwhile
Wesley looking for counterplay on the
cine trying to Target that the C7 Pawn I
am expecting the C7 Pawn eventually to
rise up two squares and once again
challenge that D4 Center that we've been
talking about but looking at the clock
situation it feels that though Wesley
managed to get that one B3 early
surprise in Magnus is the one uh who's
happier with the opening outcome Magnus
has easy moves to make but I just want
to note that when black does eventually
play C5 it gives white an option to take
on C5 either leaving black with an
isolated Pawn so let's just show that
right you can take on C5 and if black
takes the Knight hopping the Knight to
the center you have this isolated Queen
pawn and Wesley just won a game from the
white side of this type of position
against nirc abusar to eliminate the
young USC talent and if you take to the
pawn on C5 we get what's called hanging
Pawn structure and I think this is good
for Magnus considering the clock but
what happens in these hanging Pawn
structures it's difficult to move either
Pawn because if you push a pawn you
leave a square behind and let's say you
push the C Pawn then white says give me
that D4 Square I'm ignoring the fact
that's it's giving away a pawn right now
the main principles those pawns are very
difficult to push because it's such a
big decision handing key squares away to
your opponent yeah often uh there's kind
of a really split Camp here players
either love those hanging pawns or they
hate them and uh I think Magnus knowing
him a bit he quite likes these hanging
Pawns structures but it's a lot of
responsibility uh having these pawns
here they will come under heavy fire in
the next few moves so you need to be
ready and uh Wesley again non-committal
with his moves Rook to E1 looks really
really slow I've got to admit uh maybe
he'll lift The Rook up and swing it
across uh to either C2 or D2 but um
either way Magnus he's going for those
hanging pawns he's taking the respon
responsibility on and he's got extra
time on the clock to do so um looks like
Wesley less familiar less comfortable in
these positions than his opponent
yes after that first initial move and
surprise it feels that Wesley's play
play play play has been uh very solid kg
in this position but when you don't take
the fight to Magnus Magnus will bring
the fight to you and that's what we're
seeing happen in the center right now
he's put the Rook on d8 lining up with
White Queen so feels that he's ready
with the pieces The Rook from E8 will
slide down to C8 I think the big
question will come right now for Wesley
is he going to be the one who takes on D
on C5 with his D4 Pawn or does he just
simply keep the tension on the board as
is because one thing that Magnus would
not like to do here is capture the D4
Pawn himself allowing White's Knight to
jump to a key D4 square and then be
really ideally placed to start targeting
the isolated Queen's Pawn if I'm Wesley
I am capturing that pawn on C5 but he's
now done under 6 minutes the time
difference is growing between them but
capturing on C5 and then moving that
Knight on C3 back to E2 take one step
backwards just to take two forwards
you're going to LEAP into uh the
position here because when the Knight
reroutes to F4 just like in that game
against no deck yesterday you are
putting a lot of pressure on the black
center the bishop on B2 is a much
happier piece White's pieces are
coordinated quite nicely so for Wesley I
would be taking that pawn on C5 but I
would also be moving more quickly and he
does not take instead leaps his Knight
forward to B5 he's taking advantage of a
square that black can't easily kick the
Knight out of yeah he's gained a square
wle so this white knight looks pretty
strong but he's also given up this
Square it's something you mentioned you
alluded to earlier Tanya Black's Knight
on e4 often is a very strong piece
anchored by a pawn nicely supported
there it blocks out this light Square
Bishop longterm and Magnus instantly
seizes this opportunity suddenly he's
opened his own Bishop uh with all the
four Bishops kind of staring off at each
other along these diagonals it's all
about whose Bishops are better and who
holds the key to the center suddenly
Black's Bishop potentially the stronger
of the uh of the pair here and queen to
E2 evaluation bus slides down slightly
it's it's all about the clock time so
Magnus has literally double the amount
of time and uh yes no obvious Mose
Suddenly It's getting a bit sharper but
starting to like Black's position move
15 Magnus twice the amount of time on
his clock right now and the one with
more control over the center especially
with that last night jump that we saw it
is undoubtedly pressure Wesley right now
he does make the move Queen to but not
easy to find follow-up plans right now
that Queen does defend that bishop and
B2 which was
pinned just to move a goal you couldn't
capture in C5 so perhaps Wesley looking
for ways to simplify in the center and
we can expect that pawn takes Pawn trade
coming up next after Queen E2 and one
thing I really like about Wesley's KN
jump is he's eyeing that A7 pawn it
looks completely irrelevant but black
since the beginning is want to connect
the Rooks put them on the D and C files
that Rook on A8 is stuck protecting that
pawn on A7 so perhaps a clever try from
Wesley I didn't understand it at first
but now that he's protected his Bishop
on B2 D takes C5 does feel more annoying
for black that Bishop on the dark
squares in front of the black king it's
an important defender in the event of a
potential attack whereas that Bishop on
B2 it's happy to trade off the board
here so I do think that Magnus has a big
question in front of him and very often
when you're playing and every move
doesn't have to be one where you make
these big decisions David you ask
yourself which pieces can you actually
improve the one piece as you mentioned
the Rook from A8 cannot move cuz A7 is
hanging but that Knight on A6 it's done
its job it managed to get C5 in is it
time to reroute it try and find a way
closer to the centa yeah there's a few
squares for this night to jump to if we
look at all of the black pieces as you
say Tanya when there's no concrete
action when there's no kind of
calculation no attacks no defense no
threats why not improve your worst place
piece and black has two of them this
Rook doing nothing uh just to point out
Robert's idea here unfortunately this
Pawn would simply fall you lose a porn
for free uh so yeah it looks like the
remaining candidate to be improved is
this night a few options you can drop it
back try to trade off for whight but
somehow this feels a bit clumsy after a
trade you do get stuck on this open or
what's about to become an open file on
the C file stared down by the white Rook
feels a bit counterintuitive and uh the
question is do you go the other way do
you jump forward with the Black Knight
the question now persists what to do
with it next do you drop back again
towards the center this looks like maybe
the most harmonious move to me and uh
evaluation bar doesn't react that's very
good putting pressure on White Center
but it does take a bit of time and maybe
Magnus is just wondering what to do here
for example if the dart squared Bishops
disappear are these Pawn strengths are
they weaknesses can Wesley chip away at
them not sure exactly how the game would
continue the queen could give a check
for example the black king maybe forced
back and it looks relatively level to me
but maybe Magnus is looking for
something even more ambitious um I think
his defor setting though should be
improve a piece U because that would be
very logical right now well I was
growing up myel told me that a good way
to try to find your next move is ask
yourself three questions it's the rule
of three questions what's your
opponent's threat if there's a threat
immediately you counter that you defend
against it you play against it if
there's no threat on the board ask
yourself what's your opponent's weakness
in this position there are no big
weaknesses right now the play is still
going on and finally you ask yourself
what is your worst place piece so if
none of the two apply in the beginning
you go for your worst place you improve
the position uh and I think this uh this
rule has also been mentioned
by yakob aard if I'm not wrong it's a
good checklist to keep in mind because
some players think when I can capture I
have to capture that's not the case here
at capturing on D4 as we've been talking
about that will only help white black
will be saddled with an iated Pawn some
trades will happen and that's good for
the side who's playing against the iqp
so night B4 looks like a very nice move
but perhaps Magnus doesn't like the
resulting trades that we saw with A3
kicking that Knight back to C6 uh so for
Magnus who's had a big time ADV
Advantage he's using his time wisely but
suddenly it's getting closer on the
clock and that's good news for Wesley so
yeah really long think now over four
minutes from Magnus Carson Tanya ear
earlier you mentioned the okay your move
on the board nice one uh you mentioned
the play the pay look at the pay
differential between first and
second wa that was part of the plan
night A2 wow that is an intruder I've
seen yaser seran games like this where
he's talked about funny night mov but
that Knight just trapped itself over
here and in fact The Rook can slide over
and the Knight cannot escape the C3
square is covered by both the bishop on
B2 and the Knight on B5 but what Magnus
is doing is saying Go For That Knight
I'm going to go for yours in return and
after the move A6 you take on A2 I take
on B5 this is looking very interesting
but in a way that white can maybe steal
a pawn here but the queen could get in
some trouble so this is one of these
situations where calculation over
everything James Cy I see you that's
required because Bishop A6 at the end of
the line and that White Queen is in
danger yeah is she trapped that's the
big question if she takes a pawn right
now she gets kicked around and I think
she might be caught I'm trying to just
find the killer blow she's only got one
more safe Square how do you close the
net around her do you will keep chasing
her around the board is she finally
caught in the center what recognition
from Magnus to see this from a distance
he didn't just uh stumble into a pawn
sacrifice that hopefully works that's
why he was spending all that time here
that Queen is trapped and that's not a
usual place for a queen to get tra right
in the center of the board and that's
not a usual place for the Black Knight
to land on the edge of the board in your
opponent territory Knight to A2 just
completely out of the blue but to play
this move it's one of those do not try
this at home moves if you play this you
need to calculate this line till the
very end and Magnus has gone for the
move A6 and Wesley now slows down if he
wasn't to capture that pawn on B5 let's
say you take Rook takes Knight cuz there
is no other move you have to capture
Black's Knight White's Knight's got no
Square to retreat black takes it back if
you don't go for this line with Queen
takes Pawn I'm liking Black's Pawn
structure now a pawn from the side has
moved towards the center of the board
the a file has opened up this is
Advantage Magnus big Advantage Magnus
especially if he's able to get one more
move and push a pawn further down the
board establish a protected pass born
but okay Wesley does find an alternative
he realizes that yes the Black Knight is
trapped yes the Knight is also trapped
but he can first trade off and make sure
that these Bishops stare down at each
other maybe he intends to actually
capture this Knight with his Queen uh
indirectly within the next few moves
this one is really heating up Robert but
I have to say that Knight A2 idea is
brilliant chess.com game review it gives
brilliant symbols when you make a move
that's a sacrifice it wasn't initially a
sacrifice but the idea is so Sublime it
just is such a crazy decision to give
away your knife but to get your
opponent's night in return like this you
could tell it caught Wesley so off guard
so love that decision Knight A2 one of
those moves that puzzles everybody
including myself but then when you see
the Brilliance revealed Magnus Carlson
coming up with creative ideas and now he
should take back this Knight he'll take
back the pawn on C5 in a couple moves
and I I do like his Pawn structure here
from the black side yeah maybe he has to
be careful here Magnus Carson if he
takes this Knight first I'm wondering
whether white oh no maybe you don't get
time to throw in a sneaky attack on the
bishop because the Knight drops back and
saves itself but uh yeah the pawn
structure you mentioned the brilliant
Pawn structure would be this one for
black and if you can keep them alive
this is a really tremendous uh Trio so
uh we're expecting this from Magnus
Carson clocks leveling out or getting
closer towards each other what a game
this is really sprung to life just in
the space of the last three moves
absolutely Knight A2 is one of those
moments where you get a peak into the
minds of a genius this entire idea and
the followup we were were thinking about
how you can improve the position of that
Knight at the edge of the board and
Magnus just finds a way that I think no
one saw coming including Wesley so but
Wesley things are still Level he finds a
way to keep the balance going takes the
pawn now the Bishops will get traded off
and this is one of Wesley's quality as
well he could be taken very well by
Shock by surprise with night A2 but he
just composes himself so quickly and
finds the best way forward he's quite an
objective player you don't really see
Wesley take unnecessary risks so if he
can trade off all the pieces and secure
a position where he doesn't have big
losing chances he will go for that and
right now he has grab that Knight on A2
like David said the queen takes it and
plays B4 so it's kind of like hanging
pawns but there are three of them but he
is gaining access to the D4 square if
black pushes the pawn up to C4 right now
the Knight will slide into this juicy D4
square that Bishop on B7 it's a passive
piece black does have this
wellestablished protected pass pass Pawn
on C4 that's the good news but that
Bishop Is Not Great there are going to
be some long-term chances for both sides
it's a very double-edged position yeah
really strong move there from Wesley so
and it's not a pawn sacrifice we should
mention uh Pawn takes pawn it looks like
the White Queen uh is in a bit of
trouble here the pawn in front of her is
pinned but simply a slide to the right a
check and next move you regain the pawn
and actually this is a far inferior
version for Magnus Carlson here for
example if he moves his King suddenly
Pawn takes Pawn the White Knight gets
access but you don't have that strong
Pawn uh that pass Pawn that Robert was
mentioning so I think Magnus has to
pretty much install it now on the C4
square has to part with that dark Square
control but um yeah very much kind of
dynamically balanced right now and this
is a critical moment we often talk about
critical moments in chess which are
based on calculation long lines but even
trades structural changes these are
moments that define the rest of the game
so Magnus has slowed down he needs to
take a decision does he go forward with
the pawn does he keeps the tension the
line that you were pointing out with
that c Pawn moving forward it not only
gives Magnus in compensation for that D4
juicy Outpost uh the past Pawn as you
mentioned but also this A3 Pawn that's
going to be a long-term weakness in
Wesley's Camp double up the Rooks at the
edge of the board the A- line and you've
got to tie down all of Wesley's sources
defending that but Magnus takes a thing
C4 is are there any other ideas that
he's considering right now apart from uh
the seon moving forward well Magnus is
down on time for the first time all game
so that's bad news if you're a Magnus
Carlson fan Westley maybe caught him by
surprise it was a clever try with this
Knight A2 getting your own night trapped
but this D4 Square looking so available
to the White Knight I agree with David
completely that you should push this
Pawn to C4 you want to close more Lanes
if you take on B4 you're settled with
two separate isolated pawns that's
unideal but Magnus down under 2 and a
half minutes right now he could get in
danger because he may not have the time
to calculate afterwards and he reaches
out and he's making a move did he take
on B4 yeah that did look like a capture
we see that happen Queen gives a check a
trade offered anytime Magnus Carlson
offers a queen trade you've got to slow
down and make up your mind it's always a
difficult decision wow this is really
anti-position what Magnus is doing it's
not what he wants to be doing but he's
trying to clarify the matter as Tanya
says if it comes down to an end game
he's banking on the fact that the Black
Knight in the center is so active
Black's Rooks will be relatively active
deficiencies in his Pawn structure yes
Black's Bishop is a really poor piece in
these ensuing end games but uh he's
posing questions to Wesley does Wesley
keep the Queens on he can avoid the
queen trade go recapture uh the B4 Pawn
with his own Queen but uh big big
decision ahead right now for Wesley end
game or no end game tension no tension
and if the Queens do stay on the board
that means that white will be left with
this bad A3 Pawn Tanya had highlighted
that before it's a target for blacks
pieces so this was a smart play by
Magnus if he wants to shut down Wesley
so's winning chances Queens off the
board would have done the trick but
Wesley said let's keep this game going
now your Pawn on B5 is right in front of
the White Queen can that be grabbed D4
so Magnus is still thrown shots at
Wesley so that's a big shot you said end
game or no end game usually when you're
playing Magnus the default answer should
be no end game Wesley keeps the tension
going Magnus sacrificing to open up that
Bishop on B7 making it a sniper Magnus
looks away are there tactic in this
position I think Magnus in his mind he's
blundered he's just thrown away a porn
for pretty much nothing he's banking I
think he was at least relying on tension
uh some threats against the F2 Square
Whit's Pawn there on F2 near the white
king is a bit vulnerable The Black Queen
exray Vision the Black Knight attacking
it but there's no tricks there's no
traps he's simply given away a pawn and
watch out your B5 Pawn is hanging as
well the evaluation Bar says he's fine
but Magnus frustrated at himself he
after regaining compos uh compos there
drops his Knight back to D6 Wesley's a
pawn up Wesley has some big chances in
this game and maybe he was looking at
some kind of Knight takes Pawn on G3
because the bishop on B7 stares at the
Knight on F3 that Knight is currently
under attack but tactically that would
not have worked out that sa because F
takes G3 and the F5 would have been open
perhaps we can show that later but
Knight D6 that is still a good move you
see the evaluation bar which the players
don't have saying it's maybe marginally
better for White and the reason why is
that the extra Pawn is now this isolated
deep Pawn so black had it now it's
White's turn and so White's pawns are a
bit vulnerable the black Rook can step
up to A4 to put pressure on the queen
and that Central Pawn Magnus is still
doing okay he's doing okay but he
doesn't have the evalar telling him that
and we saw him react right after giving
up his Pawn uh right now Magnus is on
the defense down upon Pawn he is playing
for activity of the pieces The Rook
hitting the queen expecting the light
Squad Bishops to be traded off and just
looking at the two Rooks eyeing the D4
Pawn that black knight nicely placed
controlling the B5 Pawn I think Magnus
has enough to keep things under control
in this one he should have enough but it
is certainly Magnus Carson as black on
the defensive who needs to show accuracy
to draw this game I don't think right
now Magnus has any winning uh kind of
Ambitions in his mind he just wants to
save this one because he is down upon PA
yes he might win it back yes Black's
Rook is active Black's Knight is
actually perfectly placed as you
mentioned but uh some work to be done
Bishops off the board now and how will
black continue the pressure will the
Rooks line uh will black go for those
two weak white pawns isolated Pawn on
the a file and on the D file should be
enough to hold but uh it's going to get
Harry as both players approach the one
minute Mark and he jumps in with his
Knight Magnus really trying to force the
issue he's just trying to Hoover as I
would say everything off the board
vacuum everything off the board uh
second Pawn drops though oh but look at
this that black Rook is in the sight of
the White Queen but if you take that
Rook the Knight jumps out of the way
into e with check to scoop up that Queen
so that was really nice tactical
awareness from Magnus Carlson he's just
trying to liquidate at this stage he's
not really playing for a win but the
white king doesn't have too many pieces
in front of it a Wesley who has been the
driver seat these last few moves he does
still need to exercise some caution
really nice trick there poisoned Rook
right now Wesley cannot take that Rook
he drops back with his Knight though
trying to break the coordination between
the black Rooks there kind of protecting
each other I've said it before x-ray
vision uh but one of them is hit now
that white uh White Knight attacking the
rook in the center this is where things
could fall apart if Magnus isn't careful
he's now down under 1 minute uh then his
position could collapse instantly but
he's got to be careful now he drops a
rook back to hit the White Queen really
accurate move there to hold things
together and it was a very critical one
because uh there was no way to maintain
connection of that other Rook on the
fourth rank uh to indirectly defend the
A4 Rook so Rook A5 hits the queen not
giving Wesley time to capture The Rook
on D4 but it feels like so many pieces
are codependent right now defending each
other and Magnus still needs to be
careful because that Queen can stay
connected to that Black Knight on the
board creating threats Wesley needs to
be careful because he's down to 20
seconds this is not an easy position to
figure out I think if Wesley is given
the opportunity he'll try to trade those
Queens Knight D2 hitting the queen on B3
forcing a knight trade here and I think
if all these pieces come off Wesley with
an A3 Pawn he still has maybe an outside
shot to win the game but Magnus you know
him he knows end games like the back of
his hand he'll be able to hold that and
you can do that right now right you
trade everything off on F3 give a check
on D3 and I was going to say you win the
A3 pawn and then I just realized there's
another Rook on E1 that can step up on
the third rank at the end of all the
trades and actually Wesley survives with
the A3 Pawn Wesley will be a porn up
it's not the best porn in the world the
white A3 porn probably more of a
weakness than a strength right now but
as uh you mentioned there Tanya if you
don't win it if the Queens come off
Rooks come off suddenly that pawn could
be Priceless so Wesley recaptures the
Knight right now still Level material
how does Magnus try to compensate for
the pawn the longer you're just a pawn
down in this end game the more afraid
you become so will he keep the Queens on
Magnus loves his end games but he can
block uh this trade of Queens by
swinging Black's Rook over no he goes
for the pure end game and okay it's only
Wesley Wesley who can win now it's a two
result game Magnus needs to show great
defense to hold this game I love that
move though by pushing his Pawn he
wanted to push it one step further and
he's trying to kick the king back and
also gain some key squares for his Rook
so Wesley's king that's going to be
stuck over there on G2 on that side of
the board and then how do you push your
Pawn you'll need to line up both of the
white Rooks to the uh square but after
Rook D3 Rook E3 is forced and now
without these Rooks on the board White's
Pawn structure it's fractured which
makes it harder and harder to win yeah
if the white King was slightly quicker
if the white king gained a few moves
rushed over to the queen side kicked
away the black Rook as a blockader white
Aon would run down the board Sprint down
the board and win the game promote uh
but I don't think he's going to be quick
enough look at magnus's King now
incoming White's Pawn structure just too
weak on the other flank I think Magnus
has estimated this one correctly Wesley
Waits a bit of an odd one there with his
rook and uh I think we'll see he has to
be quick though David O a decision there
from Wes I think Wesley's a bit nervous
that if his King goes to the queen said
Pawn H4 for black could be a thorn in
his side and Magnus plays it anyway but
if that King were closer to the queen
side after Rook takes H4 here that H3
Pawn would have been tender but now the
king comes to its defense but Wesley
does seem uncertain he's bringing his
King to two squares without letting go I
think we're going to see a repetition
right here and it is being played out
and the first game of the first set of
the championship fight ends in a draw
Wesley so gets in a 1 B3 Magnus with
some incredible middle game play jumping
with that move with the Knight Knight A2
what a move that was and eventually
giving up a pawn falling in a bit of
trouble trouble Magnus Under Pressure
navigates his way through the tactics
eventually and a peaceful result but not
without moments of high tension it's one
of these games and you hear the Arbiter
talking to the players about when the
next game will
be Magnus yeah okay that sounds good to
me but it's one of those games where
both players have reason to be happy and
reasons to be unhappy for for Magnus he
had this clever night jump uh but then
he blundered sacrificed a pawn it worked
out so maybe it was a sacrifice but for
Wesley once hit with that surprise he
handled things to Perfection he was
never in any true danger so both players
it was a mixed
bag it was uh quite the tension on the
board in those moments David after D4
after 82 and even though it started slow
as a kg fight things built up things
definitely built up they build up to a
head later on and it was when Magnus
sacrificed upon porn that perhaps Wesley
so started to get a bit excited it was
here Magnus threw a pawn away threw it
off the board he played Pawn to D4
actually a very good practical move
before white is allowed to establish a
bind by putting something on the D4
square and blocking up Black's Bishop
forever so throwing this Pawn off the
board we suddenly saw a reaction from
Magnus Carson perhaps missing as Robert
mentioned earlier that Knight takes Pawn
here is not possible yes you unleash an
attack against this white knight but
after the very sneaky capture away from
the center you find your Bishop pinned
at the end of the variation black here
would be doomed the bishop or the queen
would fall you lose material so Magnus
suddenly had to recompose himself he
very wisely dropped back his Knight to
the D6 Square putting pressure as well
on this white knight and a few moves
down the line we saw another very nice
tactic from Magnus Carson in this
position he is down two pawns but he
found a nice rejoiner to save the game
Rook takes on D4 defending this Rook
indirectly because if it's captured this
KN check out of the way hitting the
white king gaining time would have won
the White Queen Queen there were some uh
interesting moments later on in the end
game but ultimately Magnus Carlson was
never in too much trouble and Wesley so
continues to be that B3 cowboy and we
see a tweet from earlier for Wesley he
said it's now or never Magnus responding
to what's not to like it's not a
terrible move says Magnus about the
prospect of fulfilling his 2023
resolution to win a tour game with 1 B3
is it now or never for Magnus he gets
the white pieces in game two will we
expect B3 oo that's going to be quite
the troll if Magnus responds and Returns
the favor with the 1 B3 we will find out
and of course the action is all
happening in Toronto the epic epic
finals that we are watching It's All
Eyes uh on Toronto and there's a party
on everyone is celebrating this big
clash in Toronto it is happening the
watch party with chess players with
chess fans from the city and we will be
back with game two action
[Music]
and uh what's your thoughts on Wesley
Soul hyper solid player you know a very
solid player Wesley is solid I think
that if he had more uh maybe
selfconfidence or belief in himself then
he could have even achieved more than he
did but what he achieved in his career
so far has already been quite enormous
and I've always found him one of the
most difficult players to get even in
the B if he can regain some of the form
that he had last year in the global
Championship here in Toronto then then
he has a chance Wesley is a formidable
opponent very rarely loses always ready
to pounce uh when you make a mistake but
otherwise it's also very difficult to
beat him so that's a great combo when he
feels the blood he's he's always there
normally I would say that the match
format is very well suited to to his
style but it feels that he's been
it's been considerably less solid maybe
the last year and a half doesn't really
look for win sometimes but he really
hates losing so it's really difficult to
beat him he's a very good person his
character is really good so um I have a
lot of respect
for a new opening for your wall is here
capture new major pieces on unique metal
posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolfree pregnant
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
here in Toronto for the tour finals with
the reigning Champion Magnus Carlson so
with this field with the format that we
have here uh what do you think is in
store for the fans who will watch this
uh I'm sure there'll be plenty of um
exciting matches maybe I have a couple
of exciting matches and the rest or this
will uh what would it mean to you to win
it again I think this is the strongest
final there's there's ever been I think
to find anything that would talk the um
final of the inal season with the seven
set match against car would be would be
tough now we do hope we have new fans
watching as well so if we do have that
uh how would you describe your playing
style um I would say I'm fairly fairly
Universal
probably I lean slightly more technical
than than tactical um depending on the
day I can play I can play any St perfect
my mind is we wish you best of luck in
Toronto thank you for joining off it
doesn't look like much but neither would
a Sicilian Defense to the untrained eye
this is a performance enhancer you don't
see it how about now manage your air
quality sharpen your performance change
the game with air
[Music]
things
hey if you're in one of these cities
don't watch the finals alone you can
join one of these watch parties
happening in your cities at these very
cool chess clubs and enjoy all the
action with your chess friends and
families and don't forget to send us
some photos while you're there as well
and talking about celebrating chess with
everyone we've got a fan Zone in Toronto
where a lot of Chess is happening it's
ch fever in the city and we've got James
ganty Who's down by the Belfast love
he's at the pub he's having fun let's
check in with James James how you
doing I'm doing great we're at the Bell
fast love at the fan Zone do you hear
that can y'all hear look at this look at
all the people behind me you got Aran
tar standing right there Eric Hansen you
got Aman it's fun it's live there's
boards everywhere it's nothing like it
Tanya back to you James this sounds like
your dream job to me buy the pub playing
chess having fun with the
boys Tanya I'm going to stay here okay
I'm just going to be honest with you I'm
not coming back
okay oh well James you got to keep us
updated with all that happens I'm going
to say
I mean we're feeling a bit bad we wish
we were there with you right
now Oso's fun of course you always have
uh you know the good night pub out there
shout out to the buddies out in Oslo but
it's we have our Toronto version of it
and I'm not going anywhere anytime soon
so you're going to have to pull me out
of here for me to leave it's a lot of
fun lot of Chess we're watching the
match so you know I know you guys are
having a good time over there too huh
Tanya and uh James I just wanted to ask
who is everyone cheering for out there
in Toronto are they cheering for Magnus
Carson or
Wesley it's a little bit of both but I
think they're mostly going towards
Wesley because he's the soft spoken oh
no Magnus go easy on me you know like
but he's really really strong we already
know this he's just trying to play the
victim card at the same time but most
people are are uh rooting for Wesley
here but they just want to see a good
fight at the end of the day David what
are you rooting for David well James I'm
going to save David here let's be honest
most people in a pub are probably
rooting for you to chess box against
Aman so when are we getting that to
happen yeah well first I'm going to show
one of these of course we going to flex
one we always got to do that of course
and then secondly aom was like yeah I
don't want to do that I'm going to
retire at the top cuz he already got a
dub he's a world champion boxer already
so he was like I don't want to do that
we're going to let cany have it and I
totally respect him for that all right
James enjoy yourself that looks like so
much fun and we'll check in with you I
don't think I'm expecting you back at
the playing Arena anytime soon but you
have a good day there
thank you you do the same I'll see you
guys
later James Gandhi at the fan Zone in
Toronto and he said that the crowd is
rooting for Wesley I can imagine I mean
last time Wesley was there the chess
tcom Global Championship he won the
whole thing he's got fans in Toronto
he's got fans in Toronto he's got fans
all around the globe and I think that
many people root for the underdog we saw
the stats at the start of the show that
heading into today's match Magnus
Carlson 75% favorite Wesley had the
other 25% will this be the one of the
four that Wesley needs Toronto seems to
be rooting for him yeah it feels like
his City pretty much his hometown at
this point Wesley so uh where he's had
so much success before and if he plays
like he did in that first game putting
Magnus Carlson under some pressure I'm
not betting against him either it feels
like this is going to be the closest of
close finals and all bets are off the
two players in their best form showing
us some worldclass chess in Toronto and
Ka did catch up with Magnus after that
game one action
that was game one and uh well Magnus
coming to the board here facing 1 V3 in
the first game what was your reaction
well I mean he's played it before
and I mean it's partly meing I I guess
but it's I mean it's a good move so no
big deal is it something um that is
offensive at all to face no of course
not okay good um what did you think of
the first game here um I was really
happy with the opening uh
sorry uh I like these setups for um for
black quite a bit um I think he found
um he found a good plan with Knight B5
and queen E2 but I was also quite happy
with my my reply there and I was really
looking for ways to to fight for an
advantage but I didn't really find them
um and then I miscalculated a bit so I
actually had to to fight for the draw a
little bit but fortunately it was not
too difficult you didn't feel under big
pressure at any at any point there no by
no means maybe there was objectively
pressure but I didn't feel it what can
we expect from game two when you have
the white
pieces I don't know yet um but um I mean
I'll try and win of course sound good
thank you Magnus Magnus Carlson he's
going to try to win game two back to you
guys there's no game that Magnus Carlson
doesn't try to win he was a bit
disappointed that he couldn't find a way
to create more chances with black which
sees the score level this is game one
set one and we're just getting started
in from the action that we saw in game
one starting from the early opening
surprise to magnus's approached to
counter it we're in for a big fight we
certainly are and in the semi-finals
Magnus Carlson could not get through
Fabiano Carano without going through
Armageddon Wesley so he made it through
Armageddon against nbea buaro little is
separating these players at the top yeah
it feels like just one or two moves
might decide this final whether that's
today whether that's tomorrow who knows
but these two they very rarely blunder
Wesley I can count on one hand the
number of times I've seen him blunder
throughout his entire career and uh at
this point it feels like it will need
something special maybe a creative game
like we saw in there kind of
head-to-head in the round robin he will
need some something magical to uh break
the deadlock Magnus Carlton starts with
the white pieces in the round robin it
did go down to the Armageddon and when
Wesley had the white pieces in game two
he shut off the action very quickly it
was a quick draw out of the opening he
wanted to take the fight to the
Armageddon do you think that could be
part of his strategy it becomes more
random if it reaches s in that Wesley
definitely wants to get to Armageddon
because that means he hasn't lost in the
four games to Magnus Carlson so Magnus
is the favorite he's the highest rated
player in chess history he gets the
white pieces in game two and game four
so two whites in the remaining three
games but Wesley as he enters the
playing Hall he's going to have to be
ready with the black pieces to Stave off
magus's
pressure now the big question is is what
will be magnus's first move of choice to
try and create his chances with the
white pieces Wesley might want to keep
it solid but Magnus Carson he is ready
for the fight he's always ready for the
fight and it's handshakes and we're off
and which move will it be oh he reached
over to the queen side I thought it
might be B3 no it's Pawn to C4 the
English opening and Wesley so replies
instantly he plants a pawn in the center
himself he puts a black Pawn on E5 and
Knight comes out Wesley again does the
same all the knights are coming out into
the center here and uh we'll get those
moves on our live board very shortly uh
but it is one of the main lines of the
English opening not too surprising
Robert and Wesley played the English
against Nord dearbeck when he needed to
beat him so Wesley plays this from the
white side most players the top have to
face openings that they enjoy playing
from the other color but after the four
nights variation of the English here
Magnus the one sitting and thinking
because he can fan ketto his light
Square Bishop by playing the move Pawn
to G3 he choose it as you see on screen
here or there were other Alternatives
but now we are going to see a central
clash and we see trades are happening in
the center of the board no Mimi opening
by Magnus the solid English and I want
to ask you cuz we've been seeing this
term being dropped around a lot Mimi
openings give me some examples what are
these and why are they so Mimi Mimi
openings tend to be non-traditional
openings or openings we very rarely see
at the top level often there's a sneaky
idea behind them whether it's the Bon
cloud with uh a very incorrect early
king move whether it's uh I'm trying to
think of other Mimi openings 1 B3 let's
say which doesn't occupy the center is
something that kind of is a rare guest
at top level and often is kind of
designed to either troll the opponent
throw off the opponent maybe some Mind
Games involved um but this is very
correct chess comparatively and would
there usually be one game opening
approach something that you don't end up
repeating in a match unless you're
Hikaru and you play Mimi openings on
every on every single turn every single
game and uh yeah normally there's a time
in a place uh we see a lot of Mimi
openings online uh often players they
have kind of pet lines where they kind
of loyally adopt certain openings even
if they know objectively they're not the
best because they know all the tricks
behind them shout out to the Stafford
Gambit and Eric Rosen out there but uh
either way this is uh much uh more
traditional stuff much more traditional
stuff and we're seeing some traditional
plans being played right now now it
looks like white though has got again a
more solid approach a more solid setup
still not breaking out in the center but
very often these openings do end up sort
of exploding in the center there is
action that happens but right now it's
just very early on very early stages
between these two players and we see we
do not have a symmetrical Pawn structure
black has traded his D Pawn for white C
Pawn black has those Knights developed
will get ready to Castle White's already
castled but if you look into the
position on each player's half not a
single piece is past Magnus Carlson's
third rank whereas Wesley has two pawns
on his fourth rank the fifth rank of the
board so white has sacrificed a little
bit of space for quick development and
that Bishop on G2 that fan ketto Bishop
it slices across the board it may be the
strongest piece down the line I actually
play this opening with the black pieces
and I like that Wesley has stopped
magnus's Pawn from going all the way to
B4 so Magnus has to be happy with just
putting it one step ahead to take out
that Bishop on B2 which then starts
targeting Wesley's Center pawn and very
often the decision here is if white is
able to get that D Pawn moving up the
board do you are you able to strike with
D4 it becomes a fight for that square
because Black's Knight often finds
itself to stop that break yeah black is
perfectly poised to stop the center from
opening uh within the near future at
least um I will just mention before we
delve into the specifics of the position
we see theall board in front of us the
clocks we will get to you um both
players have an ocean of time right now
um they've barely spent that much of
their 15 minutes and we'll get those
updated so stay tuned but uh yeah it's
all about the center right now white
isn't able to strike white isn't able to
open up uh the Bishops take advantage of
the uh development advant uh kind of
lead here so it's very much about just
putting pieces in position Bishop on the
long diagonal Rook soon on the semi-open
file and black needs to guard against
this idea you mentioned T is this just a
or coincidence that for the second
consecutive game Magnus is fing both
Bishops is there something he's eyed in
Wesley's history where maybe he's
uncomfortable with this dynamic or do
you feel like it's just what Wesley is
playing so he's reacting I think a bit
of both Robert I think Magnus does have
this kind of uh affinity for uh kind of
fing ketoing his Bishops he's played it
a lot especially the last couple of
years I've noticed he loves to just Fe
and ketto at any given opportunity but
Wesley's pretty much asked him to do so
uh especially the first game uh once
Magnus fetto once it kind of made sense
to be logical consistent and fetto both
Bishops and I'm surprised we're seeing
Magnus PA The Logical followup to his
move would be to plant this bishop on
the long diagonal then again he might be
slightly tempted now that the black
Queen's Vision towards the D4 square has
been cut off uh by her own Bishop D4 on
the cuts why not explode the center I'm
really surprised by Wesley's choice of
square for developing that Bishop
because usually you either put it in
front of the king keeping that Cal Line
open for the queen and we see Magnus
take advantage of just that he gets the
moment the opportunity to strike in the
center of course it's nothing drastic
but it is step one of White's plan right
now because that Bishop when it lands on
B2 and when it does you're looking at an
open diagonal now and this D4 Pawn break
was perfectly timed you want to line
your queen up with this dark Square
Bishop if we see that series of trades
in the center because there could be
some checkmating ideas down the line if
that Knight on F6 is dislodged so uh for
Wesley he's playing for a solid position
but now he's seeding ground to the world
number one and the C file is open Rook
can just slide on over to C1 that's very
natural that Knight on C3 can actually
jump forward to the B5 square at any
moment to try to get the two Bishops
Advantage I certainly like magnus's
position thus far and I feel like Wesley
would also prefer to have this from the
white side definitely I think uh just
the fact that he opened 1 B3 in the
previous game Wesley this is pretty much
a dream position Magnus didn't play 1 B3
but he soon put a Pawn on this Square
soon feno his bishop and it does look
really promising this this bishop will
uh become open sooner rather than later
as will its counterpart its fellow
Bishop on the other diagonal so Wesley
has to be really careful and he tries to
block the center he tries to plug uh the
middle of the board but the White Knight
attack now can simply slide back Magnus
will drop his Knight back and this Pawn
will be doomed in the next few turns
Wesley has some concrete ideas in mind
there perhaps but um I'm a bit surprised
that he played it so quickly Wesley so
this is really committal stuff he's
probably eyeing that D4 Pawn in exchange
of that E4 Pawn that you're pointing at
wh's Knight I don't think you want to go
to H4 You' probably end up getting
trapped after a move like G5 very few
squares left Knight either Falls all the
way back to E1 between the queen and the
Rook or to D2 and he does make a
decision now this means a pawn trade
Wesley can pick up the D4 Pawn he gives
up the E4 Pawn who does this benefit I
would say that white is going to be
happy in most of these positions because
we look at each minor piece as we will
see some trades initiated in the center
the light Square Bishop for white is
clearly better than the light Square
Bishop from black and so that is a
long-term advantage and we have a an
asymmetrical Pawn structure where black
has three pawns on the queen side to
whites two and after the E4 Pawn is
gobbled up we'll have four pawns to
three for white aiming from the e to the
H file so I do think that this position
it's kind of a mixed Affair and I would
prefer White's chances because the
resulting trades open up the Bishops and
Black's Bishop on C8 Rook on A8 they're
not playing their part yeah it uh will
become quite concrete I'm really
surprised Magness is even hesitating
right now thank you uh to our fantastic
producers for getting the clock that's a
nice closeup both players uh still with
a lot of time left Magnus there with
just over 10 minutes Magnus as white in
move right now and Wesley he's been
playing much much faster than in the
previous game he's up at just under 13
minutes uh so Magnus a bit of pressure
on the clock there uh dipping below the
10-minute Mark very shortly but he does
eventually capture this Pawn we see the
live action shot there and things are
opening it's those Bishops those fing
ketto Bishops on G2 B2 that uh will be
benefiting from this little transition
but Wesley I think his idea is to trade
off and uh soon to park the black Bishop
on E5 to challenge for squares and uh
challenge for this diagonal Whit's
Bishop is a bit loose so potentially
some tactics in the air and he does play
that move uh so right now it is is
getting sharp the position the center
has exploded and Magnus needs to
navigate uh that little change in
scenario what a weird looking position
where the entire diagonal from A1 up to
G7 if that King slid over to h8 we would
have a full diagonal and but that's not
going to happen but one thing that I
would consider if I were Magnus right
here is that there's a night trade on
offer I wouldn't do that I would
actually slide my knight in the other
direction up to C5 the B7 Pawn is loose
and maybe I'll reroute that Knight back
to D3 to kick the black Bishop out of
the center so that Knight on D4 for
black I do think it's a bit loose there
and so Magnus should look for some
tactics yeah that's a really nice
variation Robert I think quite an
important one as well if black is able
to for example after a trade develop the
queen bring this bishop out to a really
nice juicy Square Counterattack against
White's Pawn then things could turn very
quickly black is active as well uh so
right now in the balance but it is white
move so pressure on white uh kind of
luxury for white actually uh to have
this one move to create threats of his
own so Magnus Carson needs to be
accurate this night jump looks really
really nice and productive and multiple
ideas hidden there but look at the
clocks Magnus is down now by almost 4
minutes and just like the previous game
where we were talking about this
narrative yes the position is fine the
clock could play a huge Factor later on
and uh this position could still go
either way we're still at the critical
state of the Early Middle game yeah and
also the same story line of starting
with a solid opening but things getting
very tensed very quickly in the center
and we can see all the pieces they're
eyeing each other there are night jumps
that would open threat so a really big
moment here for Magnus because he needs
to just navigate the next few moves but
to me it looks like with that Bishop on
G2 and the KN jump that you're pointing
out that there has to be a way for white
to be the first to build pressure here I
really like your idea of Knight C5 just
getting out of any trades on E four
making sure that black queen doesn't
land on that F6 Square the bishop eyeing
the G4 Square Bishop to G4 you fight
against that by putting pressure on B7
but Magnus he's taking his time right
now and Wesley doesn't look particularly
bothered by what's happening here he's
well ahead on the clock he has good
centralization of pieces and we have to
calculate certain lines when the Knight
goes up to C5 and let's say it even does
successfully take on B7 can it get out
of there sometimes the Knight wanders
into enemy territory and it doesn't live
long to tell the tale so for Magnus is
Knight C5 a legitimately strong move
putting pressure on the pawn or is it
just going to be kicked out of that C5
square and will black be able to
stabilize I still like it because
rerouting to D3 catches my eye uh but
Magnus the responsibility on his
shoulders he can't just make a move take
it back and look for better it's really
tentative play though hesitant play from
Magnus Carlson he's now down more than 5
minutes on the clock and yeah no sight
of a move yet I will say this type of
position does tend to suit Wesley so
style because yes there's a bit of
calculation some short sharp two three
move uh lines here and there that you
have to work out but fundamentally
Black's position is very sound no real
weaknesses for black no real targets uh
that white can head for and the more
trades that happen actually the more
that might suit black because white does
have these weaknesses longterm on the
queen side so uh Wesley feeling
confident unless Magnus can unleash
something here and now and the one thing
that perhaps Magnus wants to Avid in
this position is giving a bishop pair to
Black if you're just if you make a
waiting move here like a move like H3 or
Rook C1 a kind of a non-committal move a
non-aggressive move Wesley does have the
idea of himself capturing that Central
Knight and then jumping in with F3
giving a check picking up that Bishop on
B2 and none of that really matters right
now because Magnus has taken a decision
that we were critical of he does trade
the Knight on F6 Wesley doesn't even
pause for Queen takes Knight well it did
matter I would say because instead of e3
had white jumped forward with the Knight
then exactly what you're saying would
have appeared on the board that any
knight move allows a black knight to
move out the way and the bishop on B2
would have been loose so E3 is played
that way there are none of these funny
Knight jumps but Knight B5 is still
available let me challenge your knight
to try to get that dark Square Bishop so
I think that if Wesley finds Knight B5
here any thing that could have been
worse that's behind him and now we're
talking a position where he's completely
stable yeah looks super tempting right
now a little bit to calculate I guess
after Knight to B5 if that Knight is
captured Queens might disappear I think
Queens are likely to disappear on the
dile within an next couple of moves but
uh yeah ultimately that looks quite safe
for black uh maybe the other option
would be to just drop back uh to one of
these two squares and say yes this
tension is uh a bit odd between the
Bishops but Black's definitely not
having the worst of those I think it's
more about the fact that black needs to
accelerate play right now otherwise this
bishop will be inferior to its
counterpart white B Bishop put putting
pressure blacks simply stuck at home so
that's why I feel we're all quite
attracted to this move Knight B5 kind of
accelerating the play forcing the
tactics and uh they look fine for black
and at some point as black you want to
make the move C6 to blunt out that
Bishop on G2 to make sure that that B7
Pawn doesn't remain hanging Wesley finds
the accurate way he goes Knight to B5
the bishop on B2 will be picked up so he
does get that Bishop going and once he's
able to get C6 what white is relying on
is perhaps to get the Knight back to D4
making sure that more pieces more minor
pieces get traded off but to me that
looks like we're we're headed towards a
second draw it looks very likely and
Magnus I think he cursed himself briefly
he is not happy with his standard of
play he's not even looking at the board
right now but what's just occurred is
white steals a Pawn on C7 yes the white
rook in the corner is under attack but
if black takes White's Rook white takes
blacks I still think this is what Wesley
should go down because after Bishop
takes rook and we're just going to see
this we don't have to show you it Bishop
B2 right now those queenside pawns are
quite vulnerable so even though white is
aead material at the moment you to be
really careful Bishops are long range
pieces and a bishop coming out to E6
quite quickly next B3 can be in danger
if your Magnus perhaps you just
acknowledge this should be a draw and
you make that draw happen before it gets
too late and Magnus low on the clock as
well he can push the a pawn one step
ahead and then try and get that Knight
out to B6 but Magnus West sorry will
develop that other Bishop to E6 as we
were talking about it give up the B7
Pawn The Bishop's activity is more than
compensation in this position How likely
is this to end quickly in a draw o I
don't want to put a number on it but
very high chances I think right now yes
white has a four versus three majority
on the king side but that is irrelevant
that's kind of the last Factor on
magnus's mind right now he actually
drops his Knight back and I think this
is pretty much tantamount to a draw
offer if black goes and takes this Pawn
now why will be able to take off this
black Bishop even maybe go a pawn up
again but we would see opposite color
Bishops the Rooks might not stay on the
board too much longer and I think this
might be in its final throws this game
and I'll say that the Rooks coming off
the board is really the essential point
because after black grabs this Pawn on
A3 white takes the bishop B7 Falls if
the Rook stayed on the board we've seen
Magnus win many end games of that nature
but Rook C1 at the end of the line
forces the draw Wesley goes for it and
without more pieces you can't attack
pile up pressure on squares and you
can't put too much pressure once the
black king moves Pawn goes to F6 there's
no pass pawns the players are going to
find a way in this position to just
repeat things and uh there's no hope to
play here with equal pawns on one side
on the queen side that extra Pawn counts
for nothing and uh Magnus he does bring
his King forward you can create one
passer but with the opposite color
Bishop complexes that Bishop that passor
will be stopped so matter of moves
Magnus down to less than six minutes on
the clock but for me this feels that
Wesley got out of the opening without
too much difficulty with black yeah
maybe just one or two small kind of half
chances for Magnus to complicate the
issue uh to be a bit more ambitious But
ultimately Wesley's kind of just found
really smooth ways to hold this one and
you can see both players body language
they're playing so quickly racing
towards the draw now ultimately white
will only be able to create one pass
Pawn you need two though in opposite
color Bishop end games black will
blockade on the D squares Black's King
can even just park itself on a square
such as E7 later to block uh that
advance of the E Pawn and this one yeah
simply nothing to do just it's only one
Pawn opposite color Bishops always play
on to the end especially if you're porn
up just in case at uh but at this level
at this elevated level unfortunately
just a draw no one won a game by
agreeing to a draw but this one is
regardless of how long it goes on is
headed that direction Magnus doesn't
immediately fall back with the King
implying a repetition he does move the
pawn forward so he is going to play this
one out Wesley puts all his Pawns in the
same color as his own Bishop just to
make sure that everything remains
defended yeah good strategy in general
and uh Magnus he's just going to play
around a bit how soon do you think we'll
see the draw Rober it should be soon and
I want to you know give a shout out to
Wesley he had the black pieces in this
game so many players have struggled
against Magnus Carlson but he's had no
difficulty from start to finish and it's
not a position where there any cheapos
or tactics or tricks there's just one
extra Pawn it's on e4 and that's why
Wesley parked his Bishop on D6 in order
to push that pawn the white king would
need to step forward to defend the
square but as soon as that Bishop leaves
F5 the black king can step right back in
opposition of the white king so it just
you make sure you control the dark
squares there's nothing that white can
do about it I think it's about to happen
now we're going to see the bishop
shuffling around with no way to improve
no way to even really find a way uh to
get that E Pawn moving forward but
perhaps if the King was to step in
opposition right now what Magnus wants
to do is give a check from the other
side from that E8 square and then we
will see the line that you were pointing
out with the E Pawn moving
forward yeah he will actually be able to
force the pawn through but the problem
is yes it will be an e- Pawn yes it's
just one Pawn but Black's King will
always blockade on the dart Square the
black Bishop will do a great job of
defending the A5 Pawn and the H6 Pawn
White's King will not be able to attack
them both simultaneously they're both
separated uh I think just great strategy
from Wesley just to set up everything
all the pawns on Dart squares and we'll
see this happen I think we'll see
everything uh we've been describing
unfold Magnus just playing around
repurposing REM maneuvering his Bishop
But ultimately not much progress I think
uh his final trick will be to give a
check and hope that the black king goes
in the wrong direction if there was if
there was a wrong direction there but uh
now the pawns are traded off look at the
the black king that white ewn will never
be able to bypass on the dark squares
yeah any moment now I think we'll see
the handshake can't kick that King out
of E7 that's the nature and there's the
handshake draw agreed we're 1-1 in the
first set of this title match and that
was an English opening by Magnus but he
got nothing out of it as Wesley with
clinical trades goes into an opposite
color Bishop end game a solid solid hold
by the so solid Wesley yeah Rock Solid
he'll be so pleased with himself as well
often your first black game there's
nerves jangling you know your opponent
will come for you when they have white
but ultimately he didn't face a single
problem at all he was always in control
and rolls reversed in a way where the
player with the white pieces was the
player that was in some time trouble so
uh for Magnus Carlson you see him
stepping out of the playing Hall into
the hallway in Toronto he got all of
nothing with the white pieces credit to
Wesley stubborn defense never gave him a
chance yeah very similar to what we saw
from Magnus in game one with the black
pieces so we are seeing a Ki fight
between these two players which is left
us with a one to one and uh we will be
having game three two more rapid games
and again in this format yes you can
hide but you can't you can't survive
forever from the decisive result because
there will be an Armageddon in case of a
two2 tie it's still far away and to me
it looks like the players are just
settling into a match it is a long match
it is first the best of two set and if
that's a tied it goes into the third
final set so not rushing their decisions
not playing very provocative chess so
far there's a title on the line there's
a $100,000 prize difference between
first and second if you win this
$200,000 in the bank so there's so much
at stake and there's little that
separates players at the top to begin
with so why give your opponent a victory
no unnecessary risk solid approach from
both players thus far and nothing has
separated them at all a really really
even fight and we haven't really found
one player get a big advantage or a
dominating position out of the opening
David the second one also had a similar
narrative do we saw what we saw in game
one what stood out to you yeah very
similar narrative just high quality
chess in general and chess with best
play should objectively be a draw there
was one moment maybe Magnus Carlson
would have been kicking himself that he
didn't uh apply more pressure perhaps he
could have kept more pieces on the board
and asked more questions but it was here
that uh things pretty much fizzled out
towards that peaceful outcome Magnus
Carlson we were talking about a knight
jump uh this tension between Knights is
really awkward he could have jumped to
C5 applying pressure to this B7 pawn and
if black now reacts and for example
blocks this long diagonal then ideas
such as dropping the Knight back kicking
away this bishop and the game would
continue it's hard to imagine too big of
an advantage here for white but at least
these Bishops on Long diagonals do give
you good long-term prospects and uh
instead however Magnus couldn't stand
the tension he wanted to trade things
off but it was in this position after
Pawn to E3 Wesley found a really nice
way to totally neutralize any Prospect
of an advantage Knight back to B5
profiting from this pin it's actually a
pawn sacrifice as we saw after a few
trades Knight takes Pawn on C7 now but
as we saw everything just disappeared
takes takes takes and at the very end
after a few more Adventures we saw this
Dynamic opposite color Bishops dead draw
and Magnus Carlson's not going to be
unhappy about the result but at the top
they just want to apply the pressure as
you were saying so they kick themselves
why couldn't I make Wesley sweat more
there was no sweating in that game the
result was never in doubt Wesley so
played perfectly he held a draw he gets
white pieces in game three it is
Ultimate glory on the line Championship
on the line
$200,000 for the winnner so much uh so
much at stake for these players and the
battle between the two best performers
starts uh with a kg fire and of course
celebrating a chess we also have really
cool posters to decorate your walls
bring more chest into your life with
these displayed posters they're
lightweight they're easy to hang they
look really fun and they're probably
going to inspire you to play some more
chess display.com chess is where it's at
and there is a 33% off with the code
chess it's just chess chess chess
everywhere and there is more chess
coming up as we are about to go into
game three of the big final between
Wesley so and Magnus Carlson currently
the match is tied it promises to go down
to the wire we are expecting more
provocative chess subscribers stay with
us as there's a fun trivia coming up
just for
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
n
a
[Music]
hey everyone it's Ka roing reporter for
the CCT finals I'm going to give you
guys a venue tour so coming out of the
elevator that's where the players will
be entering all their games every day
heading straight into the player Lounge
so they can sit here relax if they want
coming in here this is everyone's
favorite place this is where we have the
catering and the catering Kandy is
awesome oh oh yeah as you can see best
part of champ chest store is just right
here it's the food it's amazing I'm
having an egg burrito I'm about to be so
energized for today time the food is
amazing okay enjoy your break breakfast
burrito going to take you guys in here
so I'm actually going to say this is
where the magic happens first of all in
the corner here that's where I have my
mixone when I get to interview all the
players in between games and take a look
at this take a look at all the screens
all the equipment a lot of fantastic
people are here to make this event
happen I did say that's where the magic
happens well actually this is where the
magic happens this is the venue you guys
a huge room actually and so much
equipment in here I actually heard we
have 20 cameras rolling here every day
to show you guys what's happening on the
boards should I try a chair not sure if
I'm allowed though but okay loving the
CCT finals and thank you for joining
this venue
[Music]
tour
you
[Music]
like
Bo
as the biggest chess stars are in
Toronto we are also celebrating with
more and this time it's the chess kid
stars versus the streamers that's
happening on the 18th of December that's
this Monday and you don't want to miss
up miss out on this big challenge as the
Phenom the 10 yearold fosto from
Argentina he's just playing some
brilliant chess he's just 10 I don't
know how he does it he's challenging
gotam chess he takes on and this is one
stream you don't want to move Miss use
the command stars for more information
on this and right now it is time for the
Stars which are shining in this city and
that is the biggest names in the Chess
World and two of the biggest performers
are fighting for the finals the top
prize two
$100,000 on the line and of course
crowning of the ultimate King of the
Champions chest and look at that crowd
it is the fan Zone in Toronto some big
names there as well as we're being
informed uh we've got the chess bras
we've got Grand
Masters we've got everyone enjoying
chess James somewhere in the mix there I
wish we were there as well that looks
like a lot of fun but two players for
whom the fun has to wait it is Magnus
versus Wesley that's on game three
coming up two kg draws Ka caught up with
Wesley so Wesley so you didn't seem to
be in any sort of problem in that game
with the black pieces do you agree yeah
well so far so good hopefully I can
maintain it all throughout the game but
it's actually funny because Magnus
played the same exact line against me
with the other color like it was black I
think in 2021 so two and a half years
ago online good
memory no well that's the only reason I
played this line yeah that's the only
reason I studied this line because I
noticed Magnus been playing this Knight
F6 stuff I when actually he played It
Against Me 2 and a half years ago I've
never seen it before I was like a knight
F6 but it's actually pretty good like
it's really really solid because usually
you play Knight
B6 or or but then it also makes sense to
bring the Knight to over to the to the
king side to protect the Kings so I'm
not 100% sure if Magnus remembered our
game but actually we were following it
pretty much all the way to to the end
like that game in the online I was white
and I had to win it so I didn't really
get any chances but I think even this
Knight B5 was played there unless I'm
crazy so is that why you basically
didn't spend almost any time here you
were just completely in control on the
clock as well yeah because I just
followed Magnus game so that's one good
thing I think when you're training in
chess people always ask how you train
how you train and then some coaches you
know suggest pass all that but I think
it also makes a lot of sense to I think
it makes the most sense actually to
analyze your Rivals games like not just
bits and pieces but the entire game
opening middle and end like I learn a
lot whenever I'm analyzing magnus games
and basically the only time we've seen
you in a little bit of trouble here in
the finals is when you have been low on
the clock there against nordc Abdu
saturo is that a big part of your
tactics here to just don't get into time
trouble well I'm trying but it's easier
said than done because you kind of yeah
I think this position Knight B5 was our
game actually it's very funny but anyway
I think it's definitely part of it as I
said beginning the tournament uh speed
chess is mostly psychological like
you're not going to calculate every
single bit of detail you just got to
move and trust your intuition like Boris
Gan I think he said that you make a move
first and then you think on your
opponent's clock so it's definitely part
of the job but my time management is
actually been very poor in G in uh game
one the only reason game two is because
I just followed his game but uh uh yeah
for sure because if you get under 2
minutes you can have a very good
position but you can lose it in one move
so got to watch out for that well we're
definitely going to see this match go to
four games what are the chances you
think we're going to see it go to
Armageddon well I hope m is not
listening but I mean I wouldn't mind if
both matches end in Armageddon because
uh I mean he's a better player so he got
more opportunities with more games but
if Armageddon anything can happen so all
right hopefully I can reach wow Wesley
wants it we want it let's see if this
goes to armag getto but first three back
to you
guys Bobby fiser famously said that he
doesn't believe in Psychology he
believes only in good moves and Wesley
saw there saying that speech chess is
mostly about psychology about intuitive
play but we've been seeing both these
players burn so much time on the clock
in the early moves and we just heard
Wesley being critical of himself saying
I can't afford to do that not against
Magnus Carlson he also called Magnus the
heavy favorites I hope Magnus isn't
listening I want Armageddon so I we
never know know with Wesley how
confident is he really is he just saying
things to act a little bit like he's not
The Confident player that we know is
capable of beating Magnus as he did at
the 2019 Fisher random world
championship and as he did a couple of
days ago as well in the round robin of
the Champions chest or finals uh it is
going to be a big fight David two games
to wrap it and Wesley made it pretty
clear he's happy to take it into
Armageddon what do you think are we
going to are you expecting more
aggressive ambitious play by Magnus the
coming round potentially especially in
the fourth game I think this next one
Magnus has black he wouldn't be averse
to something a bit more peaceful and uh
ideally with minimal pressure a draw
there I think would be great for both uh
but stylistically I think it's difficult
for Magnus even if he has white to press
Wesley's so solid if you poke him too
hard if you wake him up he'll come at
you and I can see Magnus getting
frustrated if there's uh kind of this
flurry of draws if he's not able to get
any chances at all Magnus has a history
of lashing out from occasion or doing
something a bit kind of impulsive so um
I think Wesley's got his strategy kind
of all lined up all worked out and it's
paying off so far it's one of the
pitfalls to avoid Hikaru Nakamura has
lost in consecutive years to Wesley so
in part because he plays for a win
sometimes at all costs and the cost is
great here in the title match Magus
Carlson takes his seat he gets the black
pieces $200,000 first place prize up for
grabs when there's a first place prize
his name is often etched next to the
Trophy and we've spoken so many times
about how Wesley Style just frustrates
his opponents and makes them come at him
which gives him the opportunities that
he is waiting for don't poke the dragon
the dragon will poke you back and it's
Magnus Carlson who's first at the table
Wesley saw still to arrive I would be I
would be shocked if we saw another 1 B3
by Wesley to start with we've been
talking about these Mimi openings he's
done it against nbec with success he
played it in game one what do you think
Wesley has up his sleeves for this one
yeah we see a handshake Wesley did Play
1 B3 he didn't get a bad position but he
didn't get an advantage in the first
game this time it feels like he'll be
more direct more ambitious and we're
about to have liftoff stay hydrated they
get their drinks next to them uh it's
going to be a sweaty fight between these
two players depending on the opening
that we get will it be again a solid
draw or will we have more one four that
gives me hope it's the Sicilian ccil for
the kill and Magnus not just the
Sicilian playing Pawn to A6 on this last
move that is ultra provocative doesn't
fight for the center at all it allows
white a free hand it's a bit of a move
order trick it's kind of asking white to
uh open the middle of the board because
then black has much more options but
I've nearly never seen Magnus employ
this one and I think already the
frustration is building he doesn't want
another quiet battle he wants fire on
this board so rare at the highest level
that I often forget its name I believe
it's the O Kelly variation of the
Sicilian it can transpose into other
lines because in the knor Sicilian from
the black side you often include this
move A6 with the pawn going up to D6
next so just asking Wesley do you know
all the variations do you know what
transpositions can occur maybe I can
catch you off guard and Wesley he is
spending some time here he said he needs
to avoid time trouble against Magnus
Carlson I think playing D4 in the center
right now now is a good way to avoid
that long-term pressure and it's so
important to not burn too much time in
the opening because the critical moments
will arise the position will get messy
mistakes will happen and the players and
the player who has those extra seconds
in those moments that's often decisive
in this one but Wesley does take the
decision finally after spending a bit of
time with that second move surprised by
Magnus he does take out the bishop to E2
with the black pieces in the oak Ali
it's about getting that D5 break in
early on that D Pawn from D7 moving two
steps ahead is that something that
Magnus is already thinking about or
would you say his approach should be to
start developing first before a central
break normally you want to get the
pieces out and I think this last bishop
move from Wesley so might throw Magnus
off as you say normally black wants to
break open in the center very quickly
you're kind of waiting for your opponent
to commit and you react accordingly but
white hasn't committed anything white is
simply developing White's next move is
natural obvious if black does nothing
white will just Castle his King so uh
certain pressure on Magnus Carlson right
now if he lashes out a move such as D5
Black's Queen would be forced out early
I think that might backfire so um I'm
expecting a pawn push here or Black's
Knight to come out maybe the queenside
Knight either way uh Magnus he's the one
to launch the surprise uh the O Kelli I
must admit I've forgotten that name too
it's that rare as you mentioned Robert
uh but okay now we're headed into more
traditional Waters uh an open Sicilian
potentially depending on Wesley's next
move he pauses will he take with the the
pawn uh the pawn will he take the pawn
with the queen will he take it with his
knight uh lots of options here for
Wesley so and in standard Knight or of
territory we see white capture this Pawn
with the Knight and Black's pawns are in
normal positions he does in fact take
with the queen here so if then Black
Knight steps out to C6 to attack the
Queen the queen will slide back in front
of the dark Square bishop and I have to
say this kind of reminds me of some
games that Magnus has played from the
white side of this opening so Wesley is
saying you can do it I can do it too
that was his uh kind of Mantra in the
previous game he did mention Wesley that
these two had a battle in the previous
uh game but with CIS reversed from two
years ago uh so he basically he's just
copying magnus's opening he just says
okay you often Play 1 B3 I'll play B3
you played the English opening a few
years against me a few years ago against
me I'm playing it this time and now A
variation as you mentioned Robert that
Magnus is quite renowned for as the
White Queen most likely going to step
back now uh either to E3 or to the D3
Square following the best player on the
planet when it comes to opening
preparation perhaps not such a bad idea
but really interesting there the memory
that uh Wesley has about all the games
that they've played even years ago and
just how they look at openings at the
very top level the knights come out and
I was expecting Wesley to Blitz out the
next move quickly while he does pause a
little bit and he chooses another square
instead of lining up the queen against a
dark Square Bishop he lines it up
against a light Squad Bishop to me this
is a bit of a surprise because putting
that Queen on E3 later on invites
White's Rook to the D line which has
opened up already but this looks like
it's not only going to come in the way
of the bishop but that eventual Rook as
well he does want to develop his dark
Square Bishop so he doesn't want to be
in its path and right now Wesley he can
just develop his queenside Knight he
controls the center that's the good news
earlier we were talking about a pawn
break for D5 for black you often want to
accomplish that in Sicilian defenses but
Wesley has that square under his control
but now we're getting into sort of a
sicilian Dragon territory where Magnus
going to develop his Bishop to G7 that's
a long range piece and it's going to be
a fighting game I don't think it's going
to be particularly solid from here on
out yeah this is the most uh promising
in terms of the rich possibilities for
both players the most promising position
we've seen so far and something
something happened did Magnus knock over
a piece uh players made eye contact
there Magnus looked over for the Arbiter
but okay back to uh pure Focus pure
concentration on this board as Black's
Bishop has been kod but yeah this one so
many pieces on the board this imbalanced
porn structure that we always see arise
from the open Sicilian um I'm excited I
think this one it feels like Magnus is
poking Wesley a bit he's saying come at
me I'm provoking you try to do something
uh but will Wesley be
provoked that is the big uh question
right now who gets provoked and how much
risk are they willing to take uh we're
going to check in with Danny who is on
site he is in Toronto bringing us some
updates Danny two kg fights but this one
promises to be a fun one what do you
make a Wesley's opening approach so
far yeah thanks I've been like everyone
else I guess a little surprised and
intrigued by Wesley's opening approach
going back to playing 1 B3 in game one a
lot of people see the conversation on
Twitter I joked that he might play 1 B3
but I said it on the heels of a comment
that I was very serious about which was
I didn't think Wesley would go back to
E4 one because of his lack of success
against Notre Beck the comments he made
to me that he wasn't feeling comfortable
with his preparation and it's funny and
then Levy said well if he plays E4 we
will kind of learn what magnus's
intentions are by whether he plays E5
going into some really well-known lines
that Wesley can keep very technical and
and very sort of risk-free or whether
Magnus would go for a sicilian so I
guess I wanted to pop on to just say
that uh in many ways I think that a lot
of the anticipation we've had and sort
of the Intrigue about what the players
would be doing at the board is sort of
coming to life here and I'm a little
surprised by Wesley going to E4 um
Magnus playing the Sicilian but like
David just said I am also regardless of
how we got here excited about what we're
going to see on the board because I
think this is about to be the most
exciting game we've had yet and Danny
that's an interesting setup for what's
been happening but now that we're in
this position who style do you think
this type of position favors is it in
magnus's court because it might be more
open or is Wesley taking the pace
because he is starting with the white
pieces and it is closed at least for the
moment it's a great question I I mean
Wesley plays E4 we know that he as he
said for many years was a big fan of
some of the sharpest most deeply
prepared Sicilians it hasn't been
something he he has done as as uh I
guess as often in his later years as we
say he's still a pretty young guy um but
I'm going to go on a limb and say that
regardless of whose style this favors I
actually feel like Magnus is happier
about what we're now seeing on the board
it's a very unique Sicilian yes it's a
dragon setup but you have a couple of
very unique features in the position
right the Knight on D5 and this sort of
structure is is very irritating for
black but white also doesn't have as
much space as you might normally have
the queen is interesting on D3 you see
Magnus aggressively playing the pawn to
B5 which means he's ready for a fight on
the queen side a very typical Sicilian
plan so is Wesley going to play
something like A4 and try to maybe
positionally undermine the queen sight
here uh or will he stay aggressive in
the center and allow allow for an even
sharper Sicilian things like Bishop to
G5 put a rook on D1 and E1 and see if
you can make something happen so anyway
I know I didn't answer your question
directly I kind of feel like it favors
Magnus in terms of the kind of position
he wanted we also see a little bit of an
edge on the clock so that would be my
that would be my my crystal ball
prediction I
guess and uh Danny I've got to ask are
you missing Levy James everyone why
aren't you in the bar why aren't you in
uh the Belfast love right
now I I'm not in the bar cuz I got work
to do uh just like just like everybody
else here and uh I saw I mean obviously
candy had a had a good time over there
um checking in with the chess BR okay
Bishop 2g5 by the way excited to see
aggress aggression from Wesley um and
Levy is over there right now he'll be
checking in soon spoiler alert for those
who didn't know that or or fans who were
hoping to catch a glimpse of Gotham he's
he's actually over there right now um I
think I'm going to head over there at
the end of the day I don't know want to
be here just in case some crazy stuff
goes down um but uh but yeah and I I
will definitely be there tomorrow that's
awesome chess over everything Danny
we've been seeing the fan Zone there and
it looks like everyone's having such a
great time uh what does it mean for
Toronto to host this massive
finals I I think for Toronto the fans
feel better this year than they felt
about us last year the chess.com Global
Championship didn't have a fan Zone and
in the venue that we're in we really
didn't have any experience for fans it
was I think great for the players we got
a lot of compliments uh but the fans
weren't really pleased this year again
we didn't go as far as we'd like to go
ultimately our our uh future is I think
going to have even better experiences
for fans I'm hoping to to deliver on
experiences that our fans on site here
with the players who knows maybe even
with the with inability to scream and
cheer and shout when they when they see
things they like there's a lot of lot of
ways we we think we can pull that off um
so I think I think Toronto is super
pumped to be hosting uh this event like
last year obviously the candidates is
coming here so they're becoming quickly
one of the most uh one of the most
Global globally visited cities in the
world in regards to Elite chess so I
think they're pretty pumped and shout
out to all the fans who who showed up
and made it as we said it was completely
sold out the bar looks packed um and uh
and there they are right there and we
see a little bit of simplification sorry
my CH I'm in a chess bred I know I'm
normally the guy who's taken us taken us
away into the more the more off theboard
stories but I'm I'm pretty fascinated by
what's going on here because I have a
feeling my prediction was wrong I made a
prediction out there that I thought
Wesley would be so solid we could very
easily get four peaceful results before
Armageddon but I have a feeling we're
going to see some spice on the board
here so that that gets me excited and
hopefully the fans will be will be
pumped to see that too yeah that was
really cool to see so many people in
Toronto excited about this finals and in
the fanone we saw Aman in there as well
and I think I spotted Maxim not really
sure if that was Maxim but it looks
really cool Danny we will check in with
you lots of Trades have happened in this
one a very different position we're
going to Deep dive into this and keep us
updated with everything that goes on
there meanwhile we do see a lot of
trades on this one but despite that an
ambitious ambitious approach just like
Danny did predict H4 I feel like we lost
him too soon cuz he would have loved to
say something about this move H4 for the
score Wesley is just trying to expand on
the king side he can also do the same on
the queen side and Daniel was saying we
might see some spice variety is the
spice of life we're getting all these
different openings and it's Wesley who's
taken it to Magnus at the moment why not
he controls so much more of the board
right now the queen side is undeveloped
for Magnus and H4 put that pawn up on H5
and just ask some questions to mags are
you really going to develop your Bishop
to F5 yes you kick my queen away I can
just move my queen out of Dodge and then
I am still going to play H5 maybe F4
maybe G4 I can throw all my pawns up
because there's no attack against the
white king maybe A4 on the other side of
the board to try and create more
weaknesses the material is level David
but the pawn structure seems to imply
that if anyone is playing for
disadvantage it has to be Wesley and all
caution has been thrown out of the
window with that last move yeah this is
Wesley so at his best this is Magnus
Carson taking some big risks as he does
attack the White Queen which will surely
just slide back and uh there we go
Wesley does play that move I just wanted
to mention the pawn structure we've
talked about white being super flexible
on the king side with these three pawns
potentially moving mobilizing also on
the queen side it's purely because in
the middle of the board white has this
beautiful Pawn on D5 in an end game it
might become weak because it's very far
extended but for now it clamps down on
two of Black's pawns black can barely uh
challenge ever in the center if you
cannot challenge in the center white
simply has more space due to how far
Advanced this Pawn is the board is cut
in half essentially so it's going to be
very hard for Black's Queen Black's
Rooks to travel between the king side
Queen side kind of switch Focus very
quickly whereas White's Rooks will be
able to switch to the center they will
be able to kind of uh Zoom behind their
pawns if lines open up on the king side
and um K Magnus prevents the advance of
this H Pawn I think that's a really
important move otherwise black would
have been feeling uncomfortable with
this King but either way I'm slightly
biased here towards White's position
just due to the pawn structure often uh
this kind of scenario really
uncomfortable for black this is an
eternal
weakness that D5 one that David pointed
out is what defines the position and
gives any chances if at all to White
here and it's not as easy as it might
look looking at the material balance we
see more pieces being traded off but
again this keeps the position alive with
the light light squat Bishop off the
board white can start targeting even
with the F Pawn moving forward that last
move by Magnus has weakened his King
side a little bit and with the light
Squad Bishops gone it will make black
more vulnerable to attack than white and
w keeping his options open but look at
what Magnus has just done he's
sacrificing a pawn right now because if
that Bishop takes the black Bishop on F5
you're not taking with the pawn that
opens up your king that's not a good
decision but Queen takes F5 and after
Bishop takes E7 I think Mag is going to
flick in a bishop F4 because that dark
score Bishop for white is going to have
a hard time getting back into play for
instance Queen to D4 Rook to E8 if you
think you're getting away with Bishop to
F6 there might already be a rook E4 uh
idea is here getting your queen out of
line with this bishop on F6 and queen D3
I want to throw in one more a little
funny tactic Bishop H2 check when their
pieces in line with one another look
what happens when the piece in between
disappears King takes Bishop Rook takes
Pawn H4 with check you get my Rook as
well whites up a handful of material
until you lose your queen black is the
one who ends up ahead beautiful tactic
beautiful clearance sacrifices there
Robert but it's because white is
slightly loose and white does
have time to activate the Rooks and go
for this Pawn I think actually this is
just Supreme calculation from the world
number one right now Magnus Carson may
be missed by Wesley so it does look on a
superficial glance that he's simply
winning a pawn but this suddenly
backfires and white due to the Trap
nature of this bishop or actually your
move even stronger Bishop to F4 due to
the fact White's Queen is a bit loose
Sunny momentum black and Wesley so
realizing this not being greedy I think
dodging a bit of a bullet there he does
shift his Rook instead so still eyeing
this point in directly but black now has
at least
mobilized yeah that was uh that was a
stunning line that you just showed and
and what's even more stunning is that
Magnus he just quickly found it and he
finds the Tactical way to get out and
neutralize uh neutralize the position to
the advantages that we were talking but
rookie one still keeping the pressure he
doesn't go on for the trades David you
were about to say something yeah I was
just going to say why not at least
defend this Pawn now black still has a
beautiful bishop and uh despite the fact
that these Bishops these light Square
Bishops might get traded sometime soon
now uh White is unable to attack if
white ever pushes forward black will
happily step back either to the F6
Square G7 square and actually there's
just too many weaknesses now around the
white king white will regret pushing so
many pawns so I think Magnus just in
time has found a way to stabilize hold
everything together and these Bishops
are the key he's not giving away he's
trading on his own terms this is really
really classy uh defense in what we
thought was a bit of an awkward position
and that D5 Pawn which is such an asset
in the curent current position because
it does restrict some of Black's pieces
and that keeps it backwards Pawn E7
later in the game it's going to become a
Target The Rook will slide to C8 and
that Rook can slide up to C5 if the
bishops get traded the light score
Bishops that is The Rook can come up to
C4 and suddenly it's that white Pawn on
H4 that may be a bit loose so there are
going to be some counter chances for
Magnus Carlson here that D5 pawn it can
be overextended and for Wesley he needs
to keep up the pace not just on the
board in terms of creating threats but
on the clock he's down under six minutes
we were so hopeful about White's
position just two moves ago we were
talking about all these breaks coming up
white having that deep Pawn The Bishop's
looking really good where does it come
to what moment does it come to or what
idea does it come to where Magnus has
managed to uh turn this around to at
least inequality well sometimes the best
positional moves are based on tactics on
tricks and I think it was that one that
Robert pointed out just Magnus pretty
much hanging a pawn saying that was a
free Pawn try and take me but the
tactics work in my face favor and that's
where momentum changes is going in one
Sid's direction for so long suddenly
something throws you off suddenly what
you wanted to achieve isn't possible
anymore and then it's momentum for your
opponent and that's how games take this
kind of roller coaster effect and uh
they can be Topsy Turvy because um often
things at this top level are very rarely
one-sided you might be going for a
certain goal you might have a certain
idea in mind but the opponent always has
resources to try and throw you off and
yes Wesley isn't able to achieve a
direct Advantage but he's not worse it's
still in the balance this position white
still has chances and I like this Rook
lift and the evaluation bar off to the
left hand side of our screen here it's
still in the middle and it has been both
in this game and in the previous ones as
well but Magnus has done a few things in
this match that Knight A2 decision the
thumbs up from the evaluation bar it was
a great idea here sacrificing a pawn
temporarily on E7 also a good idea but
the best players in the world they know
when to choose their moments and Wesley
knows when not to take a pawn that may
be vulnerable he understand stands
that's biting off more than he can shoot
he would be in an uncomfortable position
so Wesley he is now just under 6 minutes
Magnus about to hit the seven minute
Mark and for Wesley he's just doubling
his Rooks on the E5 I like the way he's
handling some of these decisions from
Magnus they may be a bit of a surprise
at first glance but then when he sits
and calculates he realizes not a big
deal let me continue with my plan let me
coordinate my pieces and once the Rooks
do get doubled up on the E line that
will be threats for Magnus for to answer
once again with that F Pawn moving
forward targeting that Bishop on E5
again coming back to that D5 Pawn that
we were talking about it's just made E7
a long-term weakness and that's where
that's kind of like Wesley's notar
guiding his play doubling up on the E
file placing that Bishop on G5 it's all
around that E7 weakness right now Magnus
develops also eyeing a potential Rook
lift himself once the Bishops uh get
traded The Rook could come to C5
attacking D5 or also C4 hitting on H4 at
the right moment yeah and look at the
body language both players sensing this
is a critical game a critical moment
it's really hanging in the balance yes
the knights are all gone but the porn
structure is imbalanced enough and uh
the piece config configuration is really
tense it feels like one side could crack
and uh Wesley hesitating here he's one
and a half minutes down he does play the
consistent the most logical follow-up uh
to his plan enacted by lifting his Rook
up the board and now how will Magnus
react quick Pace here Trad the Bishops
your move Robert I think incoming the
black Rook on C8 needs to activate there
is for the first time in this game uh
the hint of a threat of White's f- Pawn
coming forward kicking away Black's
stabilized Central Bishop so Magnus
wants to fight against that and if white
really wants to get that in after Rook
C4 you to first play G3 but every Pawn
push in front of your king gives control
of important squares to your opponent so
I would not be touching too many Pawns
in front of my king if I were Wesley but
you can't really push pawns on the queen
side either the B Pawn is stuck Place
defending the C Pawn so I think that if
Magnus is given a few turns he can bring
his first Rook to C4 then slide his
other Rook to the C file and if white
can't successfully get this Pawn push to
F4 to kick the dark squ Bishop out of E5
I do believe that Magnus will have the
better chances there so Wesley he'll
have to act quickly on the board this
time rather than the clock yeah it's all
about that black Bishop if it stays on
that beautiful Central Square only
Magnus Carson as black can be better if
Wesley is able to kick away that black
Bishop from the center Maybe by using a
pawn then things will get tactical
things will get really sharp and uh
Wesley will hope that things go in his
favor that's why the black Rook lands on
this fourth rank cutting across on uh
that uh on that nice nice line and as
you said Robert Pawn to G3 giving the
white king some breathing space but also
re uh kind of preparing that pawn to F4
push getting so tense and uh five
minutes each now on the clock still
feels like we might have a winner in
this game it might be decisive could go
either way feels like far far from the
level the sterile equality we saw in the
previous two battles and F4 is now a
threat right which black has to sort out
because you are targeting the E7 pawn
and if that Rook stays on E8 you don't
have the defensive resource of falling
back to F6 anymore guarding that E7 Pawn
I'm just thinking that can black
actually try to fight the threat with
challenging White's Bishop on G5 with a
defensive move like Bishop F6 eventually
but for that you need to move that Rook
from E8 out of the way so I don't want
to move it to d8 let's say I double up
on C8 can white actually get to the E7
Pawn immediately okay by dropping back
this is your idea Tanya Challenge and
this is one of my favorite structures in
chess it looks like black structure has
been broken but the doubled F Pawn to
keep the black king nice and safe I call
it the bug house structure because in
Bug House chess for those who play uh
this is the way to keep your king safe
but uh yeah it's about whose King is
weaker here it would be white and he
does play your move and uh tactics
potentially in the air Pawn to f for
might actually backfire if Wesley isn't
energetic here feels like Black's Bishop
holds the for it is the glue holding
things together but it's enough and
blacks Rooks uh might be superior to
their counterparts unless there's a
sacrifice on
E7 tactics suddenly we could invert the
move order that's what I'm wondering
about right now let's say I take on E7
first so your queen is in line with the
white Rooks and then I play F4 what's
going on here this looks like a messy
position because I'm threaten to win a
Pawn on E5 I have both of my Rooks there
you can't play this Pawn push to f six
because your G6 Pawn will be loose so
now there are questions that Magnus will
have to answer the white king is out in
the open after pushing all those pawns
yeah Wesley if he goes for this he needs
to judge it correctly this white king
will be weak there's various ways black
can defend here yes Wesley might even go
up a pawn but this white king with Queen
Rooks all the major artillery on the
board I mean this is so double-edged so
moment of truth if Wesley doesn't go for
this it might be too slow I think that's
why I'm reaching out it's not the bishop
again a more cautious approach here he's
going for a rook trade but trading
pieces suddenly we mentioned it if black
keeps the bishop uh sorry on this E5
Square black is better long term and uh
yeah the black queen might come out at
some point black can kind of curl up
into a ball put a king on G7 Bishop on
F6 at some point I think Wesley might be
losing the thread he's reluctant to take
a risk go forward but maybe he had to
just be principled be aggressive there
and it's a position with a D5 pawn it is
going to be something that white May
struggle to hold because if that second
black Rook steps up in front of the C4
Rook go up to C5 put immediate pressure
on the D5 pawn and the black queen
slides over suddenly we could talk about
Magnus going for a win but I like his
decision first he brings his King up to
G7 covers the F6 Square again also maybe
in some positions you need to cover the
G6 Pawn so you can push your own F Pawn
to F6 to kick that Bishop out of there
but either way I like the way that mags
is handling this and both players under
4 minutes it's getting into territory
where speed it can kill but it's needed
here yeah feels like Wesley maybe just
needed to go for that take a risk be
energetic after all you don't beat the
best player in the world by being timid
and I do foresee a position where Magnus
can start grinding that's where we know
he loves uh to kind of exert his
authority over the opponent even the
best players in the world if he gets a
small Advantage like the weakness of
White's far Advanced Pawn now we
mentioned it trading everything off that
pawn is weak so Magnus has a few things
longterm in his sight
Wesley needs to act dynamically now and
speaking of acting dynamically now I
just want to point out that this
sacrifice of Bishop takes Pawn will not
work anymore and that all comes down to
Wesley's last move the whole idea falls
apart because that Rook from E3 which
moved to E4 has actually cleared out a
diagonal and after Bishop takes pawn and
perhaps we can show this with arrow
David that this is the idea that we were
watching for earlier which gives Wesley
the plane now afo can be met by a check
on A7 which earlier was not possible
when The Rook was on E3 so Wesley
Returns the favor steps up with his King
Sid steps the check Bishop takes Pawn
once again a threat but he did walk into
a new diagonal which I don't like either
because in the current position I
believe that the black queen can slide
to B7 in the very near future maybe on
this turn with Rook C5 to follow or Pawn
to E6 in some positions because the king
is in the scope of that black queen on
B7 this is actually a nervous territory
for Wesley so Magnus just playing on the
queen side could play with A5 saying my
Queens in the perfect location but I
don't think that the white king is fully
out of Dodge yeah Wesley's drifting look
at this Pawn to A3 he's even just parked
all his pawns on Dart squares and these
could be easy targets for Black's Bishop
later in the game I really don't like
this for Wesley so and this idea of
putting the queen on the long diagonal
not just uh threatening tactics along
that line but also Pawn to B4 will
totally shatter the white structure
later Magnus he's upping the anti upping
the pressure this is a massive weakness
it was wh's biger strength earlier
suddenly all these trades and it is
simply weak Magnus is turning the screw
he controls all of the pawn breaks in
this position because White's Pawn
structure is actually cemented in place
F4 is available but we talked about that
weakens the white king and Wesley has
not shown that he wants to get
adventurous on that side of the board he
does do it now the dark score Bishop it
will Retreat to F6 maybe after an
exchange of Rooks first as we see Magus
take this Rook but that Bishop is going
back to F6 and there may be double pawns
I just don't I think that's the
important thing the D5 Pawn is the
weakest B4 is a pawn break available to
Black and that King on G7 will actually
be tucked coily there with four Pawns in
front of it rather than just three yeah
we've seen it before that type of
scenario including in a game with Magnus
Carlson against Fabiano kowana yes the
Bishops are going to get traded off yes
it might just be queens and Rooks left
but King safety it's Paramount it's key
and White's King far more Airy drafty uh
far more open than its counterpart
Black's King is the safest King you will
ever see it's just nicely protected wall
of Pawns in front of it I think actually
despite the evaluation bar only being
slightly in Black's favor this one is
already on the brink Wesley has to be so
accurate to hold this one now and quick
capture Magnus has that beautiful wall
of Pawns now the four uh Pawns in front
of his King and Wesley's forced passive
onto the defensive White Queen and Rook
two heavy pieces the best pieces you can
have in chess they're all guarding a
mere porn this is a sad sight Wesley
goes into the defense which means he
lets go of an open file as well where we
can see Magnus try to put his own pieces
for counterplay but it all comes down to
the clock situation as well right now
Wesley's under 2 minutes Magnus under
the 3 minute Mark and despite the level
material despite black having those
double pawns we are expecting this to be
a big fight still some more critical
decisions coming up there are heavy
major pieces on the board and we know
just just how deadly Magnus can be with
those Queen placements and we typically
don't like double pawns and black is the
only side with double pawns because in
pure King and Pawn in games it's hard to
create a passer but with Rooks on the
board when you have double pawns you
have open files and why black should
have the upper hand he's been using the
C file and if that white Rook did not go
right back to E4 he could use the E file
as well so the black king has that
blanket of Pawns in front of it it's a
happy piece the D5 Pawn does stick out
but is there enough Firepower remaining
that's the central question for Magnus
Carlson the D5 Pawn can be defended by
two of wh's pieces but and only can be
attacked by two of blacks it seems like
Wesley is hanging on by a threat if
Magnus was to put that Queen from D7 the
first move that came to my mind was
Queen F5 just feels like an active
Square for the queen I'm pinning the
Rooks if we imagine this position with
the queen traded off who does that favor
oh I think Wesley would love the Queens
off because even if white ends up losing
a Pawn on the queen side if all of the
queen side pawns from a to defile
disappear then actually with four versus
three just on one flank black cannot
create a pass Pawn that's the one
downside of having these doubled pawns
that Magnus has right now so I think
actually a rook trade favors Wesley
because he'll be safe A queen trade
favors Wesley he'll be safe Magnus if he
wants to win keeps the queens and the
Rooks on if you imagine the black queen
or black Rook ever entering the white
half of the board if they ever land on
the second rank knockout game over and
uh I think Magnus needs to keep the
tension try to maneuver sneak in behind
somehow it's not going to be easy should
still be a draw maybe with play but
Wesley is just devoid of a plan look at
this he's just putting his King uh in
the corner there he's just waiting
seeing if Magnus can break through I
like the move though because now he's
putting the onus on Magnus saying show
me what you got you put your Rook on B8
are you really going to play B4 no he
goes Queen F5 and maybe he's now more
inclined to trade Queens because the
white king is so far offside so a queen
trade The Rook slides to E8 this is a
situation where only Magnus can play for
a win and he's going down this line and
that's so interesting because Magnus
waited for the moment when and Wesley's
King was at the edge of the boat so not
giving enough time to actually come to
that F2 Square to control control all
the penetrating squares on the E file
only after Wesley played King H2 Magnus
goes on for The Rook Pawn end game is
there is there hope here for black we
always talk about the Magnus touch can
he create something in this one it's
definitely possible if anyone can Magnus
can he squeezed water out of a stone
more times than we can count and this
last move is really classy it's actually
a pawn sacrifice black giving away Pawn
white can actually take twice on this
square but the black king is coming it's
all about Rook activity Black's Rook on
an open file White's not and King
Activity The King's coming in and it's
not just about open files it's not about
open ranks this is what makes Magnus
Carlson perhaps the best endgame player
of all times his Pawn structure is
ruined on the king side double isolated
pawns the f file and is Pawn the H file
but white is sitting passively The Rook
on D2 needs to sit there on the second
rank otherwise black gives a check wins
a queenside pawn if it leaves the dile
the D5 Pawn will be loose and now King
G6 King F5 that black king is entering
the fry and if white king slides on over
one square to F2 the black Rook slides
on over to H3 winning the H4 Pawn
Wesley's going to go down a pawn it's
urgent if black gets one more move two
more moves as you said Robert if the
black king activates it's over so he
tries to shut down the entry points for
the black king Black's King now has no
way to sneak into the white position uh
I think a really important move there
from Wesley so and uh Magnus can he up
the pressure the problem is he's
maximized the black is perfect the black
pawns on the queen side cannot really
Advance any further his other pawns are
stuck so it's all about the black king
and inroads he needs a rout in but he is
winning a pawn in this position like we
were talking right The Rook slides back
to E5 there is no healthy way to keep
that F5 Pawn in the position anymore no
there isn't he can go Rook e five right
now but I don't think he will he goes
King f8 because Rook e five isn't going
anywhere attacks two pawns at the same
time there's only one white Rook to
defend with it I love that move king of
eight cuz what's Wesley's move going to
be if he go goes King F2 he may just
lose the H Pawn and that's a really
valuable passer because it's not doubled
F pawns that F5 Pawn is probably going
to be lost eventually Wes is's got to
move and he's down to 20 seconds wow and
a difficult end game to defend as well I
love it I think this might be zuk Swang
and uh that's a term we say when every
move for white worsens his own position
the white king had to step across but
now the black Rook goes back and the
pawn drops with check so even better why
not just give your opponent the move
pass and uh they worsen their own
position Wesley's now desperately trying
to break open lines tradeoff on the
queen side will Magnus say yes he
doesn't need to decide yet he does trade
a set of Pawns I'm a bit surprised maybe
he could have kept some tension there
but Magnus now is up a pawn and can he
convert this is the question Wesley
defending heroically so far but it's
only Magnus who can win this one do not
hurry is the team of this end game that
king move King to fa just making
Wesley's position worse how quickly he's
able to create his chances in this end
game that's taken me by surprise and we
see now Wesley trying to build a kind of
a fortress just relying on the fact that
Magnus has the doubled F Pawn which
gives him hope to hold on to this end
game a big problem for Magnus Carlson
all of his pawns are isolated so you
can't get a connected pass Pawn
situation he moves his King into the
center this end game reminds me of the
one against gesh which Magnus was able
to Outlast the junior a super strong
Indian player in but he's going in with
his Rook he's going to Target the C Pawn
as well but Wesley's getting active not
sitting passively to defend that is so
important and now both players are
playing on second on the clock mag has
this amazing ability to recognize equal
but difficult to defend end games and
combine that with his sheer will to play
on till the end to just play for a win
till the very end and that's what makes
him the greatest player of all times
when it comes to end game but will it be
enough in this one with Wesley getting
active oh big question Wesley's King now
doing the right thing marching up the
board forcing the black Rook away but
the king's getting driven back now this
one is so close between being a draw and
a win for black Magnus he's trying he's
probing but Wesley has all the answers
so far this activity look at the white
king going back where it came from I
think Wesley's defended this perfectly
under 10 seconds Magnus now he might
have lost control is cominging in yeah
he's using his King as a weapon and
there could be some mating Nets around
the black king The Rook on A7 make sure
that the black king cannot jump up the
board but now we're going to pass pawns
on opposite flanks black already has
established pass on the B file White's
going to win the H5 Pawn it's going to
be a pawn
race and there still one extra Pawn but
it's all about who gets those pawns
moving first but it looks like magnus's
Pawn is closer to queening than Wesley's
magnus's Pawn is closer but Black's Rook
is trapped on the wrong side you always
want Rooks behind pass pawns White's
Rook is keeping that black B Pawn under
lock and key and why is he allowed the
black pawn to run his King could have
stepped across his King could have
stepped across but he was worried about
black pushing the B Pawn and delivering
a check but right now can't that pawn go
all the way up to F2 and The Rook will
go to H1 to stop the pawn it may
sacrifice itself but Black's Pawn cannot
be stopped Black's making a new Queen
mag Carlson is going to win Wesley
forgot to keep that pawn under watchful
gaze and it's game over a couple of
checks spite checks magnus's King is
going to dance easily out of them and
now just prevent the white porn
promoting we see a check first of all
and Wesley resigns Wesley resigns Magnus
Carlson does Magnus things in the end
game takes the point takes the lead in
the finals with the black pieces what a
win that was it was reticent play from
Wesley so and Magnus Carlson pounce he
senses it when his opponent doesn't want
to strike Wesley had to do it earlier
and Magnus is the first to deliver a
huge blow in this final match he does
deliver that blow in classic Magnus
Carlson style and starting with two
draws at the start of the day we move on
to Magnus Carlson taking the lead which
means game four Wesley has to win on
demand it's a must- win for Wesley so
Magnus Carlson will take set one and
we've been talking about Magnus Carlson
being the greatest player of all times
in the end game David did he just prove
that one more time there's no doubt
Magnus Carlson is one of the best
endgame players in history and that was
just clinical he started the endgame
level material somehow Magnus managed to
work things in his favor Wesley defended
so well for so long 40 50 moves he
defended But ultimately he did crack
when low low on time and I just wanted
to point out in the porn race the
critical moment Wesley simply didn't
have enough time on the clock to hold it
and it was here that after Pawn to F5
Magnus racing with two pawns not just
one Wesley did fall apart he pushed his
own Pawn when he needed to track this
Pawn the F Pawn with his King he should
have stepped back and he was afraid here
that the white king would be vulnerable
to checks but after Pawn to B3 do not
take this Pawn after you take this Pawn
you will get checked from behind next
move no matter where you go black will
promote and cost white his Rook next
turn but but instead it's now a race now
you push your H Pawn and after this Pawn
steps forward you use Black's Pawn as
shelter you step in front this is so
difficult to find maybe with 30 minutes
on the clock he would have found it but
not with a few seconds and whites Pawn
acts as just enough of a distraction to
save this game instead after Pawn to H5
we saw black win the race the pawn
pushed and at the very end White had to
resign because simply here Black's Rook
will stop the pawn on the next turn and
Black's Pawn will promote we often see
this concept of an umbrella Pawn when
someone's attacking you leave the pawn
in front of your king because it doesn't
open a file here it could have been used
in the end game so that the black Rook
couldn't free itself to deliver a check
and allow his own pass pwn to promote
impossible to find with no time on the
clock Wesley gave it his all but Magnus
he was relentless he did not allow
Wesley to escape easily and he was able
to convert for a full point Magnus
Carlson with his endgame touch he just
always plays on until the last drop of
Hope is squeezed out of the position and
this time he scores the big win Wesley
he kept up the defense but eventually
crumbled Under Pressure it's Advantage
Magnus and overall it's Advantage
Toronto because everyone there is having
so much fun right now in the fan Zone
and we've got Levy joining us with
everyone there Levy what was the
reaction with that crazy race that end
game that we just witnessed in the fan
Zone yeah Tanya thank you and by the way
great call there uh the reaction was
spectacular we got a roaring amount of
Applause this is basically something
that you would imagine if the Maple
Leafs or Canadians or any other uh
Canada based hockey team would be
playing on a Friday what is today Friday
so I think today's Friday the pub is
completely full the venue is packed to
the brim we got people here with chess
sets playing in the back and they were
screaming applauding so the advantage is
21 Magnus and we'll see if Wesley can
fight back and Levy what's the reception
been like you're there everyone you know
is excited to meet you I'm sure and I
see Fabiano and Maxim behind you as well
so what are the fans you know are they
enjoying their experience getting to
meet some of their
Idols oh it's incredible absolutely
amazing I'm actually lowering the
average ELO of the stage here I've got
Fabiano Carana I've got Maxim vrav Aman
Hamilton chess grandmas and World Chess
boxing champion at this point uh so I'm
just super pumped to be here I
interacted with some of the fans behind
me I didn't even know that uh ear plugs
had wires still in 2023 but this is
super cool this is the only way I can
hear you guys because it's so loud
behind me uh it's incredible I've never
seen anything like it for chess over the
last couple months I've done a couple of
book events in in in the states also in
London recently I was going to have one
here in Toronto had to postpone it but
it will happen in January and I never
thought I would have 4 or 500 People
Under One Roof all cheering at chess on
a screen so guys I think we're doing
something right and Lev we heard that
players in Toronto all these fans there
were rooting often for Wesley so were
they a bit disappointed to see Magnus
win it or they're just happy to see
great chess
yeah I think they just want to see as
many games as possible uh they would be
excited if let's say one of the players
won 3030 which is the minimum amount of
games you'd need to win two sets but I
think they just want to be here cuz uh
they got drinks they're having a great
time and the more games we have the
barrier Levy I see Fabby and Maxim
behind you what are they looking are
they playing music cuz it looks like a
DJ POs to me or are they watching chess
right
now yeah I don't need to continue to be
reminded that I a lower rated player
than the other people to my left but
thank you Tanya yes there are very
strong super Grand Masters here they are
analyzing games the games are being
broadcasted live to a massive audience
behind me uh and it's actually kind of
tough I'm not sure they can hear
everybody's chatting having a good time
playing some Speed games against each
other but there is a chess BR broadcast
going on on Twitch maybe on Kick as well
so they're just deep into the action and
we're getting insights from two of the
world's best players we're getting
insights from a chess boxing uh Savant
and Aman Hamilton so I mean you can't
ask for anything better than what we've
got going on right now damn lucky
Toronto that looks like a lot of funie
we'll catch up with you later been
awesome chatting and say hi to everyone
there for
us hello from
Oslo lby Rosman is down in the fan Zone
having a lot of fun and Maxim and Fabby
having a lot of fun there and the fun
doesn't stop from Magnus Carlson after
the champion chest he will be
uh trying to defend his world rapid and
Blitz championship title as well lots of
Chess coming up and so important to get
the momentum going in this match for
Wesley so as he faces the world number
one things are not looking good right
now the darkness behind Magnus is on the
board for Wesley but Wesley has to
strike back in this upcoming game
four
are you up for some puzzles James I hate
puzzles we have some puzzles you did
this last year right how'd you do last
year yeah I did very poor well I
I white to move 10 seconds yes sir yes
got another one that I've seen but I
don't remember the solution of course
you seen them all of course um
time um I think it's A4 so A4 is
incorrect okay in game you know you like
those come on you this one but not
sacrificing three points and then
winning you actually are on to something
there what you got a
H5 okay now I got another 10
seconds I'm going to guess that it is uh
it's
A4 A3 and then I think it's Knight C5
there n that's it is you got to reverse
it reverse just flip it around flip it
flip everything you close A4 is in there
so the problem is in my mind it's like
I'm trying to recall something rather
than Cal C I know seen right correct
correct this one I might actually fail
cuz like I mean it's probably H5 okay
takes yeah M yes and here of course
there's a debate yeah right G6 take yep
E6 got Bishop A3 is forced and this is
like the only moment that will trip me
up oh wait I can I can play Knight C5
take no wait I'm not what is it is
I think it's uh H5 takes G6 takes E6
Bishop A3 Y and then white looks totally
lost give away two coupon for nothing I
mean on the glance I would guess H5
gh6 D6 then Knight B4 and the pawn queen
and and A4 exactly beautiful beautiful
and I think it's might be G6 F E6 Bishop
a knight B4 Bishop B4 A4 e to H stop the
[__] stop he keep going that's it that's
it you got it right he
T E6 Bishop A3 let's go Dennis okay
Bishop takes one more let's go let's go
ah let's go take H5 H yeah GH G6 yep
takes FG M yeah E6
okay Bishop A3 yeah only move yeah night
before Bishop eges got them let's
go um wait do I have night before take
A4 that's it there we go dub come on I
don't I don't know what it is the
problem I need a fresh one so that my
mind is not actually trying to remember
cuz then I spend like 5 Seconds trying
we fresh ones guys we need fresh ones
forar he's seen them all guys he's seen
them all no Taro has seen this one
recall test for him so you seen it
before right white the move 10 seconds
uh I know know you saw I know okay well
go ahead definitely tell the camera we
got I'll just say queen of five check oh
yeah queen of five check in the end yeah
yeah it's probably my least favorite
type of puzzle yeah correct that is 100%
correct I've seen it but like I I don't
yeah ah it's so annoying because I I
don't want to uh no I would go with
Perpetual if I if I I was playing in BL
bullet yes fast yeah not that's not the
solution of course yeah I have no idea
I'm going to guess it it's Bishop takes
E6 nope nope okay Knight F6 or something
Knight F6 baby okay he got the right
move but she got to finish it though bro
he got that chip in his brain bro he got
the chip Knight of six exactly right
throw the iPad like what is this no no
way no
way no no no way no I I of course I
would if I would think like one hour or
yeah you probably find it so Knight F6
Bishop takes C3 E3 F3
and then after King takes G6 oh there's
Queen to F5 and Bishop H7 there it is
total iPad ah Queen F5 oh heat he got it
let's go byro let's go baby yes sir ah
queen of five come on there it is yeah
nice very nice very nice a pretty it's a
pretty one very hard been very difficult
well I'm interested to see how I guess
he would be the best here yeah or maybe
yeah we have to recall kind of he's
actually seen it one seen it
I have no chance congratulations on
winning the event in fact I mean uh well
I'm I'm just waiting for the check
waitting for the check but we warmed you
up Wesley you feeling warmed up baby
come on man Flex Le so here right thank
you very much congratulations on all
your success man we'll see you in the
turn I hope I can Fu my queen like that
please we'll love to see
[Music]
it
I think he's going to lose on the clock
Wesley if he doesn't lose on the board
he's he still needs to save it on the
board especially after that last move
Whit for getting active Wesley smiling
he knows it's going to be all over soon
20 seconds and Magnus wins wow look at
that Magnus Carlson in
armagedon finally beats Wesley so and
look at that reaction that is
huge wow David what do you take away
from that I've never seen the world
champion that emotional there it is the
final game and the final win for Magnus
gson in the 2021 season what a
performance it's been by the world
champion to win the Tour overall Wow
first result uh today between Magnus
Carlson and Wesley so Magnus Carlson
takes the lead the winner of the match
the winner of the mwater Champions chest
2022 and the winner of the tour finals
leaving the San Francisco Arena with a
slight smile on his face he is a true
champion Magnus
Carlson cson is the two times champion
of the tour looking to strike twice this
time and these two have quite the
history between each other they' played
each other a bunch of times and Magnus
Carlson with a massive 32- 17 leads and
look at that number of draws but no
surprises they're given Wesley solid
style but Magnus Carlton leads that
hectic head and he leads set one of the
finals of the Champions chest star after
that game three win and Ka did catch up
with the endgame
Maestro wow what a game Magnus Carlson
takes the lead and what a game Magnus
what was the Breakthrough here I think
um one big factor was that um I mean
this is this was um like many of my
games Wesley actually that he's doing
well uh he's even a bit better U but
he's playing like a little bit too
apprehensively um and then I sort of
used that to eventually create chances
um give him and give him some choices
and you know once it comes down to time
trouble it's it's not easy um so I
thought um yeah I thought it was um was
a good psychological game
um yeah once he um
uh once he started to play Passive I was
just trying to see can I can I keep the
game going can I get any
chances and uh yeah I'm happy with the
with the way that it went yeah they said
quite early in this game our experts
that this is this feels like a game that
is such a balance between a draw and
just somehow a breakthrough and a win
for minus did you also feel like that
for a long time in this game yeah well I
think I was definitely worse at first
but yeah eventually it felt like um I
was the one who is pressing for sure the
only time really we've seen Wesley in
trouble in this tournament so far is in
time trouble so is that a big part of
your tactics against him to get him into
time trouble um yeah for sure um so uh I
think this is also what happens when he
starts to feel uncomfortable okay now a
game four with a draw you will be the
winner of the first match what can we
expect um I I don't know I mean I didn't
really expect to win this one uh so I
haven't thought too much about it but um
you know we'll see didn't expect to take
this one is it just about taking the
chance when you feel there is one yeah
for sure I mean um I didn't have any
chances at all in the first two games
and uh it's a little bit like like
yesterday or I did match with Fab I
didn't get so many chances so when I get
them I need to take them you definitely
did in this one thanks Magnus good luck
in the next one thank you all right he
took his chance and he's in the lead
back to you
guys
and Wesley needs to take his chances
because a really key insight there by
Magnus Carlson that Wesley is playing
apprehensively David there was this
moment that Wesley could have taken the
pawn on E7 with his Bishop but again
just cautious play for him and that
seemed to have cost him big yeah he
could have gone for some tactics and
they weren't unfavorable for Wesley he
just needed a bit of Courage he needed a
bit of composure as well but ultimately
Wesley tried to take the quiet way out
but in the end though this was a signal
for Magnus Carson just a hint of
weakness and Carson capitalized so here
we see the handshake the players getting
ready to start Wesley needs to be braver
in this next fight he needs to be brave
because if you don't take the fire to
Magnus he will burn down your position
and that's what happened in game three
Wesley must win with the black pieces
Magnus Carlson needs only a draw what
will he start with and oh was that
hesitation no he goes with one E4 does
that surprise you in a game he only
needs a draw it doesn't surprise me at
all because Wesley so loves playing E5
on the first move and Magnus feels I can
just force the issue make a draw send
this to the second set with a one-nil
lead so for Wesley he might try out the
Sicilian Defense but it's not in his
comfort zone to have to play for a win
for move one and he does play the
Sicilian and Magnus puts Aon on C3 the
C3 Sicilian the alipin Sicilian as it's
sometimes known and this is uh renowned
for its safe uh Tendencies here for
white often a bunch of Trades happen in
the center at the very minimum sometimes
white even gets an initiative uh if
black is to uh kind of oblig to fight
here and okay KN coming out pawns
pushing what do we make of this a good
choice for Magnus Carlson a great choice
from Magnus Carlson and not just because
I play this opening my entire childhood
I think it's in incredibly safe unlike
in some other Sicilian lines where files
open we don't get a symmetrical Pawn
structure if we look at this position
position and Magnus can push his D Pawn
up to D4 we're keeping pawns on the same
files so he's not allowing Wesley to get
small pluses maybe a semi-open line here
an possible Rook sacrifice for a minor
piece like we seen the sharpest
Sicilians really good call from Magnus
Carlson yeah really interesting to see
this opening um Dynamic that we're
getting Magnus chooses the King's Pawn
opening inviting Wesley to go for the
Berlin because the Matt situation
doesn't allow that and that's where
Wesley feels the most comfortable so
Magnus draws him into an opening that
perhaps Wesley doesn't want to make but
doesn't have a choice to forces him to
go for the Sicilian and then keeps it
closed with the alipin yeah and uh this
queen capture I'm slightly surprised by
I must admit Magnus uh in the world cup
that he won earlier this year in the
final game of the whole world cup
against pragnan Ander just needing a
draw with white he employed this opening
the alipin but it wasn't with this
variation bringing wh's Queen out so
early he just took with the Paw and
played more classically shut down that
game easily made a draw and uh won the
tournament so I'm slightly surprised
Robert and normally we don't bring our
Queen out so early because it's easy to
kick that Queen around but the Black
Knight when eventually lands on the C6
Square white will pin it with his light
squore Bishop so Magnus trying to figure
out what move to make right now he can
take this Pawn on D6 the dark squore
Bishop will have trouble taking it back
because that Queen eyes across to the G7
Pawn so we're just looking at this
position Magnus he doesn't want to take
too many risks he doesn't want to give
Wesley that feeling that he has even a
chance but he doesn't want to too much
time either because we saw that backfire
for Fab on car one against Magnus
Carlson in their game four where Fabby
was up two games to one yeah and it's
always precarious uh it's always tricky
this situation where you want a draw
it's in the back of your mind but you
shouldn't necessarily aim straightfor it
you shouldn't play for it let it affect
your decisions too much and end up
taking negative kind of suboptimal
Impractical decisions and uh right now
Magnus in the tank for a minute or so um
it feels like he's kind of torn into two
minds does he play ambitious aggressive
chess and maybe kind of take a route out
later if a draw presents itself or does
he really try and force the issue try
and trade off as many pawns as possible
pieces uh everything uh right now Wesley
shading his eyes Magnus not known for
his death St but Wesley uh really here
his body language focused purely on the
board I think he should be relieved at
least that Magnus is the first one to
Blink to think yeah and that's quite a
tin that Magnus is on right now he's
touching the 12 minute mark very early
on takes the decision to develop the
bishop instead of grabbing that D6 Pawn
still inviting the Black Knight to jump
in to development wire C6 hitting that
Queen on D4 but I do like this approach
by Magnus uh of just continuing with
development even if he's surprised with
this last move by Wesley he takes what
is the common principle of openings and
I think he's just sort of praying on the
fact that Wesley has shown a reluctance
to trade too many pieces in a must-win
game even in that armag get game against
nck Abdu satarov yesterday that final
game of the Epic semi-final between
those two there were moments where
Wesley could have initiated some trades
he instead backtracked with his pieces
so in the center right now there could
be a trade of a pawn a trade of a knight
but why would Wesley want that when he
feels like he needs to win some more
pieces on the board at least in theory
sound like a good thing for Wesley are
you surprised we saw a bit of a shake of
the head from Wesley he was looking down
at his fingernails there just thinking
ah he doesn't look too positive um but
this position is still full of life
there's only been a trade of one set of
Pawns you got to be uh you got to be
focused you got to just block out the
results of the earlier game I was just
about to say that do you think that's
because of what has just happened in
game three as well because everything
was so under control with Wesley in in
that opening getting that position with
the bishop bear the pawn on D5 we felt
he was the one who was putting pressure
but then that lack of courage in that
one moment where he didn't take Bishop
takes pawn and and are these thoughts
that would haunt you going quickly into
game four Wes he's a competitor and a
competitor in any game or sport when you
just lose a very critical game you're
going to feel it and unlike in a
classical chess tournament where the
next game starts a day later you had a
quickly maybe get some refreshments go
to the bathroom and then sit down to the
board again so how could Wesley not be
upset about what just happened he does
have a decent position here he's trying
to Shield his eyes from his opponent
because he needs to play the position at
hand and then you remember you're
playing Magnus Carls and he doesn't give
you too many chances to begin with in a
position like this we're still early
part of the game but out of the opening
I don't think Magnus is particularly
unhappy yeah Wesley continues to shake
his head chess is not only a battle on
the board but an inner game as well and
right now for Wesley it is about just
trying to forget what has happened a
game that was in his control but messed
up in the end but you have to let go of
that and focus on the board right now
Wesley now to me Knight C6 would be the
obvious move that you want to Blitz out
what are the other options or perhaps
development ideas that black can be
looking at here David I I just think
bring the Knight out bring the bishop
out trade off pieces get castled it's
actually quite straightforward I don't
think you have to be uh too
sophisticated about it he does hit the
White Queen I'm expecting him now to
maybe trade off a set of Pawns in the
center just go back to basics when in
doubt especially with the clock
situation just speed up just trade off
get the black Bishop out get castled and
only think later the game is still in
its infancy here um I'm really shocked
to see Wesley in the tank for this long
it is the hardest thing in chess the
thing chess players hate the most to
lose with white but he has to forget
that now has to recover he's got black
he's out of the opening in decent shape
and okay he's doing the right thing he's
getting ready to Castle focusing on the
basics right now but for Wesley it's all
about creating chances a must-win game
and we are going to head to Toronto
where uh we've got Dany joining us right
now Danny a difficult difficult moment
for Wesley
yeah thanks Tanya and uh everyone's
stuck with me right now because all of
our other commentator guests are still
at the fan Zone having a great time KY
Levy and the crew but yeah I just was
going to jump in to say tensions were
were high the emotions were were really
big for Wesley after that game he kind
of quickly exited and and did what he
does a lot which is grab his iPad and
then he leaves he leaves the room
because they're not allowed to have
Electronics in and then does whatever he
does to prepare gets fully fair play
scanned back in when he comes back but
normally you see a slightly uh a
slightly I guess more stoic uh Wesley
but he he wants this bad and he was he
was frustrated with how that one got
away from him we saw early right I mean
we all called it you could see there was
decisiveness in the air the moment that
sort of odd unique Sicilian was there
but uh pretty tough to lose with white
and now now has to find a way to get the
dub with the black pieces Danny you're a
father you know you also are a friend of
Wesley's looking at him on camera right
now what do you think he's feeling and
what are your thoughts about what Wesley
has to do to try and win this
game it's tough yeah because you know
Wesley uh is is is such a such a
sweetheart and um I think really thrives
in the environment where he feels kind
of comfortable and confident and I want
to say supported and I think when a game
like that gets away he like anyone else
I think is going to struggle to forget
it especially in these formats that we
have now with very it's very fastpac
it's awesome for all of us the
commentators and the fans but it's
difficult on the emotions of any human
being when something like that happens
and you don't have time to to take a
walk and take a breath and and shake it
off right so often the players you can
almost see them in their own head
they're sort of doing the mental
therapeutic work on themselves while
trying to solve their next problem which
in this case is actually I think a very
big problem that Magnus posed for him
it's a smart one to play the alipin
Sicilian obviously we know that these
lines can be I guess I'll say very
difficult for white to get in serious
trouble right this is not an English
attack not idor if this is not a
Yugoslav attack dragon or even a con
Sicilian this is a position that as you
can see it's very tame the pawn
structure borderline symmetrical there's
not a lot going on here and so I think
the alipin was a very smart choice and
an interesting note that with magnus's
286 in the last game Wesley went for the
very sharp D4 line and loses time with
the queen even when technically playing
an alipin structure C3 or even C4 are
actually the more common moves there so
Wesley didn't want to get something tame
when he had white now he regrets that
there's something so tame on the board
by Magnus cuz it's going to make it hard
for him to win the win is what he needs
at this point and you were the first to
call out in game three Danny when you
joined us that you have a feeling that
this is going to be the most exciting
perhaps a decisive game uh of the day so
far and I want to ask you with the
Dynamics right now playing the black
pieces the alipin on the board and so
much pressure of trying to create
chances how are you expecting this to
play out how how do you foresee uh this
one developing
well the good thing is I think Wesley no
matter how heartbroken he might feel
right now you look at him and your heart
goes out to him because he knows he's
fighting an uphill battle he's not going
to go down easy here he's going to make
sure that we have drama on the board
because look a draw is just as bad as a
loss right at this point one of the cool
things about the format is in the set
setting if you lose 3 or in Armageddon
it's only one0 heading into tomorrow and
he's been down one0 before it was
against Notre Beck in the semis Magnus
is different but I think Wesley
understands the Dynamics he knows what's
at stake this isn't going to stay tame
the moment he gets any any bit of an
opportunity he will look to mix it up
but again the problem is this is a
position that will come with an
inherently large amount of risk to mix
it up because there aren't a lot of
natural structural weaknesses in the
position as I'm sure David and Robert
will you know all of you will do a
better job explaining um than than
myself but it's going to be tricky right
you got to you got to take your chance
if Magnus slips even just a teeny bit or
you have to try to create something out
of nothing which is going to come with a
lot of risk yeah difficult tough spot
for Wesley Dan we will check in with you
as this one is developing uh thanks for
those insights and uh meanwhile the
alapin fight does continue still a
closed position still Wesley trying to
create chances along that diagonal the
white the light Squad Bishop for Wesley
will land on B7 so perhaps in the future
we can expect some activity on the long
diagonal yeah this uh lost retreat by
Magnus Carlson uh I had half an eye on
the evaluation bar it did slide down
slightly and uh it does look provocative
it feels like black has a very tempting
first move I'm not sure what the
follow-up is but uh Magnus now he's
inviting Wesley forward and as we've
spoken about in previous games sometimes
you have to jump on the opportunity you
cannot be timid um yes this bishop is
really well placed on the diagonal but
it will get there anyway so maybe jump
forward with the black knight profiting
from the fact that the White Queen okay
he plays it the Black White Queen has
retreated to a vulnerable Square square
and I think magnus's idea was to come
back I'm not sure which Square exactly
he wanted to use maybe this one uh now
this Knight is a bit loose threatening
to jump forward with his Knight to hit
the black queen but even if the black
queen preemptively slides back herself
suddenly this Knight is on a beautiful
square if you team it up with this
bishop longterm there will be potential
tricks and there's nice juicy holes on
the light squares if you can get to them
I think Magnus wants to bring his Knight
forward but now this black knight at the
very least drops back maybe drops back
this way and at least there's easy play
it's nothing decisive of course magn
hasn't made a big blunder or anything
but a bit clumsy for white with this
bishop struggling to get out and easy up
Moose for black we started with a
sicilian but this resembles a French
defense and Wesley so he became a
grandmas on the back of playing the
French defense he loved that opening
growing up and this position it's really
nice for black because you have that
active Knight on F4 you're going to put
your Bishop faneto in the long diagonal
and for Magnus maybe he's playing a
little too timidly he knows the result
he needs he just wants to make a draw
and get out of here with a one set lead
but black does have legitimate chances
because the pawn structure is not
symmetrical we have a four on three
Advantage for black over on the king
side we have a knight in enemy territory
there's a D3 square that that Knight can
hop into and the most natural move is
Bishop to B7 The Black Queen will slide
back to C7 uh the this type of position
is one where there's an imbalance and I
would definitely prefer Black's chances
yeah feels like he's achieved a lot and
if white is forced to take this knight
ever then black has this long-term
Advantage this is something you can play
with forever you have sorry my arrows
going crazy there you have the bishop
pair the two black bishops will wreck
havoc across the board a bit later on
and uh this feels like the type of
position Magnus Carlson would be begging
for with black and uh this time he's
stuck on the white side D I just want to
continue this it doesn't matter because
Bishop B7 wasn't played and I was just
wondering if white could neutralize that
Bishop at the key Advantage you were
talking about with ideas which still
exist in this current position that we
have on the board at some point perhaps
the white Bishop will trade it off uh
for the light squared Bishop once it
lands on B7 first preemptively Wesley
Soul steps back with the queen so now
whenever there's a KN jump there isn't
any attack on that black queen but the
last two moves by Magnus right the queen
was on the center of the board it was on
a nice E4 square and just two moves it
finds itself on F1 voluntarily getting
itself there is that a sign that
something's gone wrong out of the
opening definitely I doubt Magnus
envisaged this game and kind of planned
to put his White Queen on such a passive
Square the Queens are the most active
pieces we've seen a lot of dancing from
both uh kind of both Queens here but
it's definitely the black queen that
sits in a superior post White Queen will
need to activate I think she's uh she's
kind of banking on this fact that she
can support White's Bishop going to A6
as you mentioned Tanya trading off the
lights guard Bishops that's the only
reason Wesley paused there but uh
ultimately Magnus is not gone according
to plan and uh he hasn't done anything
too wrong it's uh kind of as Danny
alluded to white doesn't have any real
weaknesses to probat but certainly uh
Wesley's got everything he could have
dreamed of so many pieces still on the
board this small imbalance of Pawn
structure and uh the game is alive
that's already step one and if I'm
Wesley I avoid what Tanya was advocating
for for white to do that Bishop A6
trading off the light score Bishops
maybe he pushes his own Pawn to A6 to
eliminate that possibility you want more
pieces on the board we've already seen
that preference from Wesley so if that
Bishop takes the n and a four yes that's
a trade but we get an imbalance black
has the bishop here it is an open board
state so I think that wesy would not be
unhappy about this kind of trade so I'm
with Tanya I would avoid this light
score Bishop trade we'll see how Wesley
continues as he is a minute behind on
the clock yeah this is one to avoid
right now the Bishops disappearing
because suddenly less ammunition simply
less control over the light squares so
PA to A6 would be a really classy move
from Wesley so I think magnus's idea is
to plant a knight in the center in the
near future try to trade off uh these
little beasties and still white is solid
but weso has enough to cause some
problems a bit later on he's thinking so
long though on some of these turns where
if Wesley was confident feeling uh in
the zone you would expect the Moose to
be flying down on the board it's just
instinctive stuff there's no right or
wrong here it's just stylistic choices
and Wesley it feels like he's racked
with self-doubt right now it's just this
position when you have to win the game
it's so uncomfortable because you're not
playing your normal just okay if I don't
win my opponent played a great game
congrats to them we move on to the next
one he needs to win and he is a solid
player that's his nature he doesn't want
to take unnecessary risks but when
you're in a must-win game you do need to
make uh speculative decisions you might
need a sacrifice a piece just for some
play to cause your opponent to get
scared and Magnus does not look scared
he's not scared of anybody he's just
chilling Magnus is chilling Wesley
perhaps not so much the most natural
looking move on the board the bishop
development you really don't want to
make it because it allows the trades as
we've been talking about he puts the
other Bishop for now on F6 so more
active Square again just Bishop B7 is
the move you want but you're avoiding
White's Bishop to slide to A6 just for
now and Wesley it's high tension and if
you're feeling the same kind of stress
that Wesley is right now what you need
to do is listen to some Loi Girl music
and chesc has a cool Loi girl track and
you can check out your favorite tunes on
any of your favorite streaming platforms
platforms YouTube Spotify SoundCloud
they're all there play some chess to Loi
Girl music chill out to some Loi Girl
music it's the one you've been listening
to at the start of the stream it's
pretty chill Wesley not so chill right
now not so chill you can tell Wesley
he's barely kind of broken away from
that uh really tense body language he's
just been focused on the board which is
great but sometimes in Jess you need to
take a step back you need to just kind
of get an O General overview of the
board and kind of get out of your own
head at least uh kind of calculate but
don't kind of Stew don't philosophize
especially in these rap rapid games six
minutes left on this board it's pretty
much Blitz now but Wesley he's not had
to make too many difficult decisions
feels like the kind of momentous
occasion it's catching up to both of
these players especially with their time
usage so if I'm understanding you
correctly you're telling Wesley to
calculate but not over
everything sorry James sorry
KY yeah pretty much
calculate enough to kind of get the
moves down on the board but don't think
about the previous game don't think
about the match situation don't think
about the opponent who's sitting
opposite you just focus it's these 64
squares these uh remaining pieces and he
eventually played Bishop F6 which is a
very good move but it cost him a lot of
time so what you're saying it could be
anything but for Wesley it shouldn't be
Carlson over
everything Champions chest T over
everything it is the Champions chest T
final set one which is on this is the
game for and Wesley so has to win and
demand given his must-win situation the
fact that he's playing perhaps the
hardest the most difficult player on the
planet let alone in this
situation it's going to be a tough one
for Wesley but he's managed to create
some imbalances some chances out of the
opening that Knight nicely planted on F4
if white ever wants to give that up it
means parting with a bishop which gives
a longterm Edge to Black the move that
we've been advocating trading off the
light squar Bishop there are problems
associated with that you'd love to get
that on the board but visualize the
bishops come off the board that night
from f f and further than jump to D3
once uh the trades happen and I think
this would give black additional chances
to fight for the advantage if you're
going to play Bishop A6 you probably
have to take that Knight off the board
first and then black says I am happy
that I didn't develop my light score
Bishop yet because now I can trade
without having spent a turn in between
and and I think the best piece on the
board for Wesley so right now is the
17th piece the clock Magnus he has spent
over 3 minutes on this very turn here
he's down to about five minutes himself
it's not like this is a clarified
position pure end game just Shuffle
around there are some big decisions for
him to make yeah I think he will take
this Knight eventually simply because
there's nothing else there's no other
appealing moves that black knight is too
strong and white struggles to get fully
organized while it survives uh but he's
burning so much time because top players
they're really reluctant um it's one of
my big uh biggest weaknesses for example
I'm so attached to the bishop pair we're
kind of ingrained all we talk about
Bishop pair that's a big success you got
them survive the opening survive the
middle game and you'll win the game
eventually in uh the end stages with
this bishop pair so he's just coming
kind of overcoming his Prejudice here
his kind of uh ingrained bias of these
long-term advantages ultimately you just
have to snap off that night just play on
it's still relatively balanced but
Magnus struggling right now four minutes
on this one move that's half his
remaining time on this one occasion he's
feeling the nerves too he's human Magnus
Garson at times he can be but right now
he has made the move Bishop E3 so not
going for that Knight trade that we were
looking at still keeps the tension on
the board uh what he wants to do is
slide with that A1 Rook on the edge of
the board to the center of the board
again the idea is to trade off as many
pieces as you can to try to get closer
to that draw and he goes for the idea
that you suggested to stop Bishop from
landing on to A6 so the move A6 not only
hinting at a future B5 which you want to
be careful about because you leave
behind some of the dark squares but more
importantly you take away a key idea
from Magnus here you take away the key
idea of trading off the Bishops and
Bishop B7 coming up next absolutely in
the best part of Wesley's move he played
it quickly we've heard the best players
in the world say that it's better to
play a good move quickly rather than the
perfect move slowly and Magnus he is now
Down 2 minutes on the clock under 4
minutes from him we know it's a big
moment for both of these players maybe
Magnus is also susceptible to the nerves
and he's trying to figure out do I bring
my Rook to the defile start trading a
pair of Rooks I think for Wesley you
trade maximum one pair of Rooks at this
moment you can't liquidate fully I think
it was Emanuel lasar in the early 1900s
when he said when you find a good move
look for a better one but in today's
time and age you find a good move you
find a decent move you might as well
make it especially in this format or you
will get flagged yeah
as simple as that and I was going to ask
have you ever seen Magnus spend this
much time in a rapid game we're only at
move 17 when it's relatively quiet when
it's quite straightforward decisions uh
it's not too sharp not too
complicated I must admit I'm really
really surprised the way Magnus Carlson
has been handling that clock uh the
position is still fine enough but yeah
definitely nerves kicking in I feel it's
strange especially when we compare it to
the previous game he was playing with
the upper hand had lead on the clock
this match has been won defined by two
solid games to start and then some
apprehension as Magnus put it from
Wesley in game three and it's Magnus
who's been apprehensive in this game he
played an alapin Sicilian a quiet line
but that was Queens on F1 it's not
participating the way he would like one
pair of Rooks is able to be traded right
now he can do that and he in fact does
he could have played that move a lot
more quickly but Wesley intelligently
takes with a piece that's not the Rook
his Rook is tied to the pawn two squares
in front of it and he keeps more pieace
on the board I also really like that
because even if that pawn was defended
Robert taking it with the Rook would
invite another exchange on the board
with White's Rook sliding further so
Wesley wants to keep as many pieces on
the board that defile doesn't matter
right now because that's where the
trades will happen meanwhile Magnus does
capture the file right now Rook D1 on
the board Wesley can slide back with the
Bishop from where it came from an active
post he's managed to get the Knight to a
nice spot the bishop on B7 is on a good
diagonal how do you see him making
progress from here David well firstly I
think Wesley should play a quick move he
adjusts a piece teasing us teasing his
opponent there and uh I just love the
fact he recaptured that Rook on the last
turn with his Bishop instantly if he
keeps that momentum keep playing quick
moves here uh then you'll put Magnus
under even bigger pressure he literally
has doubl magnus's time um I I'm loving
that Bishop coming back where it came
from maybe the Black Knight on C6 can
just get out the way leap out the way of
Black's light squar Bishop at some point
unleash that Beast unleash that uh kind
of diagonal and I see so many ways to
improve I'm not sure whether there are
any big threats created but um just
speed up Wesley keep that lead on the
clock he's looking for tactics cuz
there's that Bishop on B7 staring all
the way into White's Camp Knight takes
G2 does not work here for Wesley so but
you know he's considering because Knight
takes G2 if you take back with the queen
Knight E5 suddenly multiple pieces are
hanging that Knight is pinned to the
queen behind it that light score Bishop
can can back up right he can go back to
E2 just to defend that Knight but you
need to look in this direction if you're
Wesley so I think at the starting point
Knight E5 first is available because the
KN F4 loses Defender but there are going
to be tactics at play here if you take
on F4 I take on F3 with check then I
pick up your Bishop on F4 and White's
King side is in chample so you need to
be really careful if you're Magnus if
you're Wesley don't try to cash in too
quickly by sacrificing pieces yeah he's
certainly calculating something but he
spent so much time it's definitely the
nerves making these two players freeze
we saw it with Abdu satoro yesterday in
the semi-finals I like this night move
as well just hinting that you might
sacri kind of capture and shatter the
white king side on this Square he puts
his Bishop on E7 instead bit of a kg1
I'm not sure how that improves things
maybe he's going to try and line up on
this diagonal as well with a bishop on
this diagonal uh kind of a corresponding
Bishop on the other diagonal some big
attacking chances long term but it did
cost him a bulk of his time Advantage so
still really tense we're really favoring
Black's position I feel but uh will it
come down to nerves in the end that's
the big question right now when you're
playing against Magnus you have to make
the most of every single Min detail in
the position and that clock is not a
minute detail it's a big one for Wesley
the advantage on the board is based on
his piece activity peace placement but
bigger than that it's the pressure that
he can put on Magnus on the clock so he
needs to keep the speed up even if it's
about not finding the absolute best
moves we keeping the pressure going
meanwhile Magnus trying to trade off as
many pieces as possible to ease out any
attacks any tactics related with that
night takes Pawn idea that you were
talking about he improves further the
position off the queen but Advantage
Wesley scoring the bishop Bear Advantage
Wesley it's not just the air quality we
see in front of us it's the peace
quality in Blacks got the superior Queen
the superior Bishops now kicking back
White's light squared Bishop momentum
definitely on black side and now he can
potentially afford to trade pieces
because long term the two black bishops
will gain in power the more pieces that
disappear from on the board they'll gain
in scope and uh wow committal move by
Magnus Carlson opening up light squares
around the white king Robert I saw your
face that the black light squared Bishop
is loving uh the fact that this has just
happened when there's an enemy fian
ketto Bishop on the long diagonal like
this you typically don't open up even
more but more important to Magnus is
kicking that Queen out of there there's
LT created for the black king so there
won't be any back ring checkmates but
now that Wesley brought his Queen to G4
we see the makings of a Checkmate attack
if the queen and Bishop line up on that
diagonal that white king is in a world
of hurt yeah Magnus has to be so careful
but look at magnus's clock one minute 30
and Counting suddenly big threats
Black's Knight just any move literally
jumping out the way will unleash Terror
along the diagonals now and look at the
black queen she's just lurking nearby
Magnus must be feeling uncomfortable he
took half an eye half a look at that
clock and he needs to move he needs to
decide he would love to get the quein
off at any cost here all the Rooks off
at this point but even that is hard to
achieve because Queen E4 trying to trade
the queens that Rook on D1 is loose
loose pieces drop off and there are many
loose pieces in White's position right
now so Magnus he's dipped below a minute
Wesley sells three plus to his name this
is looking like it's dangerous territory
for Magnus Carlson and he tries to
eliminate some of the danger by trading
the Queens yeah I think a good practical
decision for for Magnus especially low
on time you don't want to walk into any
checkmating attacks you don't want to
allow your opponent to create these
nasty threats when you have no time to
react that being said we mentioned it
end games will favor Black still and uh
Wesley he can tra try to hustle Magnus
there will he be reluctant to enter an
end game though after his previous
experiences against Magnus in that phase
of the game that's the big question and
that's a really important one because
you revers the colors right now and
Magnus would Blitz out the queen trade
blitz out the Knight trade and go on to
play this bishop bear end game and
probably squeeze a big win out of uh
well I can't even say nothing here
because the bishop air is something but
for Wesley does he decide to keep more
tension on the board given the matth
situation or play a position where he's
fighting for two results but really only
one will work that end game it's either
playing for a draw or a win with black
what do you think will be his uh final
decision here how would he approach this
and he's touching the two-minute Mark as
well Magnus under a minute process of
elimination I think he has to trade
Queens here because White's next move if
black doesn't hang the queen is to put
the bishop on e4 and trade off even more
pieces is so I don't think Wesley has
much of a choice in fact trying to keep
more material on will backfire so trade
queens and then count your pluses you
have the two Bishops he does trade those
Queens off the board there is that
long-term Advantage it's pawns on both
flanks the Bishops should reign supreme
over the knights yeah especially on the
dark squares Black's dark Square Bishop
is uncontested if it can ever sneak
behind white has pawns on the queen side
that are uh sitting on that color
complex so still long-term Trump cards
but I think he's too afraid of Carlson
the endgame mro here anyone else in the
world he'd be trading off a set of
knights he'd be playing quickly
confidently trying to improve the black
bishops bring the black king towards the
center uh everything that we're taught
to do from a young age in that end game
stage but you are playing Magnus Carlson
and suddenly the time Advantage is
pretty much gone Knights off the board
as well it is two Bishops against Bishop
M Knight can Wesley squeeze this one out
it's not going to be easy I always say
an arm again you have to be Shameless
you know this is not an Armageddon game
but it's a must-win game for Wesley he
brings his Bishop out putting pressure
on the night if he gives Magnus isolated
Pawn that could be another something in
his back pocket a small plus there but
Wesley he's looking away from the board
he's calculating with his ear yeah that
Body Language by Wesley isn't the most
confident one that I've seen he does
make the moves that are the correct ones
but takes his time and now it is Magnus
who's touching the 30 second Mark will
we see further Rook trades not for now
Magnus moves with the king so he's
inviting Wesley to actually capture on
D4 give up the bishop pair but in
compensation Wesley will get a weakness
off that isolated Queen Pawn do you
think it's more important to keep the
bishop a Wesley deciding not to trade
yeah do not trade because taking that KN
would also most likely lead to a rook
trade you don't leave yourself with
enough pieces yes white might have one
weakness but you need two in order to
win any end game you need two weaknesses
to probat so keep as many pieces on the
board as possible he's now hitting the
white knight kicking it back the Rooks
do disappear but more importantly he has
the bishop pair you need as many
imbalances as possible here it's the
bishop pair and the versus three
Advantage uh the four versus three lead
importance that you have on that right
flank and white has a three on two on
the left hand side of our chess board so
you guys are pushing pawns yourself if
you're Magnus Carlson but when you push
a pawn you may leave new squares assess
accessible excuse me to the black pieces
so I like the look of this end game for
Wesley throw your pawns forward he
starts with Bishop C6 but F5 and E4
those type of moves are coming but this
could be the moment where Magnus tries
to challenge this bishop that we're
talking about and he does it with the
move Bishop to F3 and Wesley immediately
declines it it is the biggest Plus in
Black's position but this in return
gives Magnus a very active spot for his
own bishop and D5 targeting the F7 Pawn
the Knight can now jump into play uh
first he blocks down that Queen side now
a threat on the board that Bishop from
D5 can go to B7 starting to attack the
queen side pawns yeah will he dive in
with his Bishop Magnus Carson go for
Black's weaknesses those pawns can still
push no he's simply trying to trade off
as many pawns as possible now a bit of a
threat to advance this white C Pawn
that's just moved one square further
fixing it on a nice protected Square
pass Pawn for good forever so most
likely we'll see a trade and uh the more
pawns that disappear the closer Magnus
will get to that desired draw although
one bit of bad news for Magnus Carlson
is that his Pawn on B4 is on a dark
Square to defend it with another Pawn
also on a dark Square only Wesley has a
dark sword bishop and oh he's actually
offering a trade of all pawns on that
flank hoping his Central Pawns will do
the trick but I think you don't want to
see all these simplifications happen
this is surprising David look it down I
think Magnus now can advance okay he
actually does go for all the trades to
try and eliminate pawns I would have
been tempted to step forward there
because Black start Square Bishop
suddenly would have been locked out of
the game but no it's uh liquidation time
he's trying to go for opposite color
Bishops here Magnus Carlson he might
have saved himself and I think that's
the key move Knight C4 it forces the
bishop trade yes black gets an extra
Pawn but it's not going to be enough
anymore Knight 4 was a defensive key
resource that Magnus was relying on
we've seen this story before earlier in
the set where it was Magnus up upon here
he's down upon with the opposite color
Bishops there's no hope you have a light
Square blockade the dark Square Bishop
can help you in that cause but Wesley
that move A5 he could have tried for
more at that moment just trying to
liquidate the queen side was not the way
to go and it looks like these are the
last few moves being played off set one
Magnus Carlson on the brink of taking
the set away this is going to end and in
a draw this is a creepily similar Mirror
Image to that earlier game with opposite
color Bishops it is a draw piece on this
board but Magnus takes the set set one
to Magnus Carlson Wesley so has to
strike back in set two Wesley missing
some opportunities right there to make
Magnus Sweat Just a Little More in that
end game he allowed the pieces to be
traded off you see Wesley looking to the
side he had legitimate chances there he
was outplaying Magnus Carlson a
tentative Magnus Carlson that we don't
typically see but what we do typically
see is Magnus Carlson and victory he won
the first set over Wesley so by winning
game three he earns a head start as we
go to a best of three tomorrow is a new
day but Wesley so needs to write the
ship quickly Magnus goson there takes a
set one we saw him shaking his head at
the end he's always critical of his own
play despite the result of the match at
the end and it is true skill that even
when you are not playing at your best or
at least according to you at your best
you still find ways to beat the very
best in the world Magnus Carlson takes
the lead with his win in set one wesy
saw has to strike back tomorrow in a set
two to take it to set three that game
David not not an easy ask for a player
to create Chances with the black pieces
but Wesley managed to do just that
Wesley did manage it with black that was
the dream he had a small but long-term
Advantage ultimately however it didn't
prove to be enough but it was a case of
history repeating itself with Wesley not
choosing the most decisive moves maybe
taking the safer approach when he should
have risked it all and it was here that
things did start to fall apart he has
the advantage we talked about the bishop
pair these Bishops are beautiful on
these perfect diagonals and I was
shocked to not see Wesley start to throw
pawns forward on the king's side this is
the side he's stronger with a pawn
majority push the pawn to F5 bring the
king towards the center push the pawns
until they can't be pushed any further
instead however he started to retreat he
brought his Bishop forward first of all
dodged this this bishop trade but
suddenly white got active white with a
strong bishop and a few moves down the
line after being offered this Pawn trade
he did actually trade everything off on
the queen Side Pawn to A5 was the final
mistake if instead he'd played Bishop to
D4 trying to come in and a Behind still
some winning chances however Pawn to A5
did allow the sequence we saw in the
game opposite color Bishops Magnus
sacrificed a pawn but dead draw W say
allowed too much activity for magnus'
pieces in the end game what Magnus does
best is he restricts his enemy pieces
he's allowed to keep the pressure
because of that so Wesley he
unfortunately didn't play an F5 move he
would have had chances but when all said
and done Magnus he held steady he made
the draw he got the result that was
needed cautious games at the start of
the set one but when Magnus had his
opportunity he strikes for Wesley those
moments were few but he missed them and
that was the decisive factor in this set
one coming up there is a big one and
what do you think Wesley needs to take
away from everything that's happened
today and switch up for tomorrow well
that's what Magnus said I I think that
Wesley was apprehensive even in a moment
where he had good position he had some
pressure he didn't actually push forward
he held himself back and Wesley he's a
very accurate player one of the most
accurate players of all time he rarely
loses but then he rarely plays Magnus
Carlson on this stage with $200,000
first place prize up for grabs yeah and
Wesley's played fantastic chess this
entire Champions Chester final and he
has to find that same courage going into
day two right after this set one Kaa is
right now with Wesley let's head over to
Toronto he is uh standing here thinking
Wesley so this uh day one in the finals
definitely didn't go the way you wanted
I guess Wesley how are you right now
yeah I think my play was okay I mean I
was just wondering if I had any real
chances at all to save the third game or
to win the fourth game but I couldn't I
couldn't find any I think I
was I mean me I think my play was
relatively at I should I shouldn't
really have lost the third game I was uh
no kind of panick didn't realize that
the end game post any threat like I
underestimated his G5
business uh I mean should still be a
draw but I mean I should have grab that
pawn like HG FG
FG and then I'm sure like after Rook E5
then probably play some B4 and I'm sure
it's a draw but yeah the way I played
this
really dangerous I think it was still a
draw in the end with this Rook on E5
King D7 King
F4 but uh uh yeah as practically was
very difficult with seconds on the clock
definitely yeah um we did have Magnus
here after that game three he said that
he felt it was a psychological win do
you think he was able to get inside your
head a little bit today and that that
was the problem for you well it's been
in my head for many years actually it's
getting better
so I mean I'm I'm getting better in in
that
regard uh but it did I have to say also
I was looking at you in game four it
seemed that you were still thinking
about game three it seemed that you were
a little down that you were maybe
completely in that game four is that
correct no not really it's just I'm used
to it I mean it's
just you know you don't really want to
lose a wi game in such a short match
that was really crucial so I mean I've
come back from defeats many times in the
past so I'm used to it wasn't really
thinking uh what went wrong you know it
is what it is uh but uh yeah it's kind
of inexcusable to lose a white game in a
short match um now also I was wondering
what opening to play against against one
E4 but
uh uh yeah mean as long as I have
chances you know I'll keep playing I
mean everyone knows Magnus is a better
player I think if I was playing somebody
else on game four I think I might have
gotten good winning chances because the
position was quite tricky and with the
bishop there I could play on maybe Queen
G4 was a mistake because after Knight F
D4 I thought I could take Knight D4
Queen G4 Knight F3 King G2 Knight E5 but
he has Bishop E4 which is very fortunate
actually if he doesn't have that then
he's probably just losing so it was
pretty close I think General my play was
quite okay today but my time
management and uh also during time
scrambles Magnus is just much better so
I have to keep an eye on that but uh
yeah I wish I wish I could play a bit
better than it would be a real match
well you mentioned the word chances in
here and there's definitely still
chances you have one 4 game match
tomorrow and then potentially and
hopefully for you a third match so yeah
what needs to be a little different
tomorrow for you to be able to make that
comeback well I tried tweeting today h
it didn't really work no tweets tomorrow
maybe no tweets today and tomorrow as
punishment we'll see if there are any
replies but uh so I didn't tweet the
other day and then I lost another back I
tweet today and lost maybe let's try no
tweet but I mean I'm not really
superstitious or anything I just try to
keep the same routine every day and uh
uh what works I mean I'm very pleased
also by the way with the co
collaboration of Chess atom and the
Champions chess store to bring two
different people together uh but uh you
know last year was a bit easier without
magnos so that's so that's the only
thing I mean sooner or later you're
gonna have to run into into Magnus so um
you know if I'll try to as long as I
have some life left in this match I'll
certainly uh give my best and just yeah
I mean try to make it a a good a good
match for for the fans I think like
Fabby played really well in the
semi-finals it was I didn't see all the
games but I think it was very exciting I
hope I can do the same yeah oh that's
awesome Wesley no tweets tomorrow but
it's gonna try no tweets today he's
gonna try for a tomorrow as well no
tweets so no no need to go into Twitter
but uh tune in tomorrow because this guy
will try for a comeback back to you
guys there's definitely a life left uh
Wesley so has to win uh set two for that
and I've said it before I'm going to say
it again Magnus Carlson lives rentree in
his opponent's head but Wesley needs to
find a way to get Magnus out of his head
space right now for that big one and
we're going to head over to Toronto for
more breakdown on the
action thanks Tanya and just like that
we have one of the matches in the books
Magnus Carlson takes the first set in
this title match here and Magnus we uh
we saw Wesley say at the end that he won
the global championship last year here
but he said sooner or later he knew he
would have to run into you here in
Toronto were you were you at home
wishing you were here last year as you
watched Wesley win
this I wasn't thinking that much about
it
like honestly the the match between
Wesley and hukari was such a slug you
know just a draw after draw after draw
and nothing was happening I was thinking
yeah fine let them do that I don't I
don't remember what I was doing but uh I
was thinking that yeah I don't want any
part of that all right well today you
got the job done take us through that
game three when did you have a feeling
despite playing the black pieces but
that that that might be the game where
you could strike I think game three was
all psychological okay I mean first
I I was definitely worse from the
opening but I guess when you play a to
A6 a move to kind of expect yeah
um and then first I offered him a Pawn
on E7 he didn't take it uh I don't think
he had much if he took it so that was an
okay decision for sure uh but later on
Phils felt like he was playing a bit
apprehensively uh and when he played F4
weakened his position I was thinking
that well the position is equal but now
I have a chance and first of all
psychologic
I have I have a chance here and that has
yeah as I mentioned before that has
really been the story of my matchups
with Wesley for so many years that the
way that I beat him is that I
just you know I hustle
[Music]
him
I I I mean I use like his sort of lack
of aggression against him right and love
him sometimes and so I mean because he
generally plays really well like he
makes very few um positional mistakes
and so on so I was trying to keep the
game
going guess it was a draw for a long
while like he did really well to create
counterplay but yeah eventually I um I
uh I got there and
um um yeah sometimes you have matches
like this where you know um there aren't
a lot of chances for either side
obviously has some he had some chances
in the last last game but um you know
when you get that one chance take it
need to take it two days ago you had a
two two match with Fabiano two wins two
losses Armageddon uh do you prefer that
type of close match that ends that way
or do you like I mean today it felt very
very tense but it did feel like you just
had a little bit apprehension from
Wesley do you like the hustle win or do
you like a back and forth kind of more
uh you know decisive results both ways
no I kind of prefer the kind of match
that I had today except that I mean I
would have wished to
there to be more of a progression like I
put pressure I put pressure and then I
break through more than nothing happens
and suddenly I get a chance and break
through but I mean it does feel really
good to win on a day where where I
really felt like I took my only my only
chance in fact it seems like you have a
lot of energy today like the game even
you just it seemed like you were really
in form today did you do anything in the
last 24 hours to contribute to today no
um no nothing too much uh I guess the
only thing is that the last couple of
days I haven't eaten before the before
the round because I felt like I've been
eating too much and feeling super
sluggish some of the other day so I
thought like let's go with the clear
heads theory for the first game and then
eat a little bit uh throughout
um um yeah throughout the matches very
you smart it's great hearing your
thoughts is awesome we actually wanted
to throw some stats at you while we had
you here and show you what your uh
performances looking like on paper um I
guess these stats are interesting you
could say that 98.1% 96.43% your
thoughts on how well you play today when
you see it on
paper um I think as I talked about
earlier it some says something about the
complexity of the games yeah uh and
especially game to like I couldn't have
made any mistakes even if I had tried
yeah cuz there was just
nothing uh going on but yeah it felt
like first game was fairly correct one
and in the third I felt like I didn't do
anything especially wrong I just took my
chances so yeah I'm not surprised that
the the accuracy is is I was going to
say I mean jokes aside obviously made an
interesting stats joke but I I really
wanted to show that it's not like that
joke is overused now 100% but I did it
because I wanted to ask you specifically
like what is it about Wesley you two
guys just we've seen matches won where
some someone is 95 and someone's 85
right this was this was a game several
games where you guys are just really
grinding each other I guess like you
said you had one chance and you took it
and you expect more chess like that
tomorrow versus Wesley yeah I it goes
with both strength of the players and
also style you could see that um notb
just drags Wesley into fights where both
players make mistakes like crazy time
trouble and everything and and it is
true that my games with Wesley seem to
be for all the for all like my talk
about hustling like my my definition of
hustling and others might might be
different mine just means you know
taking some more right some slight
slight risks playing Wesley so many
times having so many games with Wesley
of course here is there any separate
preparation or something different for
MCH like this comes to openings you said
you kind of like figured it out a little
bit too as well is it what goes into
into that um no I think you sort of take
it take it game by game by game cuz I
was thinking about it
before before the game like what first
moves to play with white especially
and I've tried everything against him
like in the past and you
know it's um yeah I think you just have
to take you game by game just to jump in
on that uh the game the second game you
play Black he obviously didn't play B3 I
said when the show started that I
thought Wesley would open the match with
d because if he opened the match with E4
you would play the Sicilian do you think
if he started the match with E4 you
would have played C5 A6 like were you
ready for A6 Sicilian right off the bat
or is that something you have to kind of
is that like a game three opening is
there such a thing as a game one versus
a game three opening yeah it's a great
question um no actually I think it makes
more sense to play even more sense to
play to play it in game one since um
your opponent may not be ready for a
surprise at that point um but um yeah I
don't think that would have made a
difference well work to Perfection today
we wish you the best of luck tomorrow
whatever you're going to do this evening
to stay ready so we'll see how tough a
nut Wesley proves to crack if we get a
long day or if you take it in two either
way good luck thank you see you then
good there he is that was the man Magnus
Carlson who took down Wesley so in the
first game of our title match the first
set if you will of our title match it
was four games in total and Magnus won
by a final score of 2 and 1/2 1 and A2
as you can see there and yeah I think
again like a lot of people say and feel
Levy summarized it in our pregame show
you kind of expect Magnus to do things
like this even if there's a part of you
that is rooting for it to go the other
way you want Wesley to have that that
that extra whatever peping his step that
maybe pushes it a little longer maybe
he'll have it tomorrow and pushes longer
guys but today it was all Magnus and
right now it's all fan Zone we're going
to check in with C because right after
the postgame interview she hustled over
and there you are in the fan Zone and
the fans are still
live they definitely are Danny I just
had to go check out this place after
hearing you guys talking about it and
it's so cool like walking in here you
walk past Grand Masters you walk past
the chess fans standing together with
them the atmosphere here is just so cool
let me hey can we get some love for
chess all right yep yep I mean this is
just the place to be in Toronto today it
is so cool to be here um I wish for
everyone at home that you would be able
to join us here tomorrow obviously
that's not possible for most people in
the world but I will say this call up
all your friends your family it's a
Saturday tomorrow get them together you
know make some good food hang out watch
the drama on the final day of the CCT
finals tomorrow because this is just so
much fun this is awesome back to you
guys
Danny yeah I know
know thank you ka I agree great great
call to action put together your own
chess viewing party and get involved on
social
media it was a viewing party out there
it was it was so nerve-wracking you you
had you sweat through your suit you had
to change clothes apparently yeah yeah I
had to go upstairs grab the coat to get
over there for my break and then uh and
then I I realized I had sweat through
the first Blazer so I wore black cuz you
know it was a tense match here today
right and uh it was a it was a it was a
weird match it was definitely it felt it
felt like it was just over all of a
sudden yeah it it felt it definitely
felt a little bit of hon from Wesley
like I was watching that whole third
game develop in the bar and when I or
whatever the the the the belf love
Public House essentially a very nice bar
uh and I was watching on the screen like
oh wow Magnus playing a really
provocative opening and then it just
kind of was a was a calm game and I kind
of got the sense like Wesley's got to go
at some point and he went but with less
than 10 seconds on the clock in a rook
hand game which is just about the worst
time to go right versus Magnus like to
step on the on the gas so yeah no I
think actually one thing that I love
about these games is that the learning
aspect like at home for me I mean I just
feel so good watching these in games cuz
now I'm more comfortable to go to in
games cuz you can see now you're not GNA
play it like Magnus will but you're
going to feel much better and seeing Oh
I got an end game let's try to you know
be inspired to I'm I'm going be inspired
to
lose I feel like when I look at these
end games I go well I would lose that
position with either that's how I feel
when I watch these games but I don't
think anybody I don't think I've ever
met anybody in the world who loves chess
as much as you can I just say that on
camera I love how much and he is he is a
student of the game if anyone doesn't
know James Cy but seriously it is
nerve-wracking CU I feel like I would
lose from either side but I just want to
go back to agreeing obviously Magnus
said it not trying to to to pile on even
further but there was
something something not so so Flex Le
Santo today right he had the pawn on E7
there were moments where he could have
done it he didn't Magnus use his
terminology hustled his way yeah to our
first title match victory yeah I wanted
to ask Magnus before he left there this
you there's so many things want to pick
his brain on like specifically that
question I'm not sure I fully got my
point across I might have rambled but my
question was we had debated what
Wesley's opening move was going to be
and Wesley should up and played B3 but
if Wesley had played E4 I predicted a
sicilian and I didn't know if Magnus was
like ready to play a sicilian game one
or if that's something you kind of throw
on a guy in the third game of a match
because you realize you have information
just like in poker from the first two
games that oh he's tentative so if I hit
him with a sicilian now it might really
mess him up ni but also that last game
you know it's always fun for me to to
see Magnus get into an end game where
he's like microscopically worse and
Magnus sits down and he's like oh yeah
oh yeah oh you think you could beat me
you dare use my my own spells against me
Potter and then he just draws it in 10
moves like you know because if the
colors were reversed we'd be like there
we go Magnus is going to work his magic
but it was over it was just a draw and
not much of a fight so I said something
similar to the to the only monitor we
have in the building that's not on delay
as I was watching it I was like there he
goes Magnus just taking the life out of
any chances Wesley had but all right
we've had a lot of life here there's a
lot of life ahead remember this is not
over Wesley so has beaten Magnus Carlson
in matches before not just here but uh
in Oslo we're going to talk a little bit
more about their full career and rivalry
against each other more tomorrow as we
all maybe hope for this thing to go the
distance cuz we love content we love
chess maybe everybody besides Magnus
Carlson wants that so all right we got
things to do I think I'm going to head
over to the fan Zone I don't know about
you guys I got to get there before it's
done but for the whole crew KY Levy Ka
everybody working hard here everybody
working hard in Oslo thank you so much
join us for day two it's the title match
of the 2023 Champions chess tour and
we'll see you
then and it is 1 V3 Magnus Carlson
shakes his head he is surprise first
game ends in a draw why is he allowed
the black pawn to run black pawn canot
not be stopped wesy resigns Magnus
Carlson does Magnus things in the end
game it is a draw piece on this board
but Magnus takes the set set one to
Magnus Carlson Wesley so has to strike
back in
[Music]
set
oh
[Music]
okay
what